chers collègues nous allons reprendre
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît nous
allons reprendre la commission
reprendre la Commission et nous
accueillons ce matin Madame Valérie
saintoyant délégué de la mission interne
ministérielle de lutte contre les
drogues et les conduites addictives
autrement dit la mille des cas monsieur
Julien Morel d'Arleux directeur de
l'Observatoire français des drogues et
des tendances addictives
l'oftd et du docteur Jean-Michel Delille
psychiatre président de la Fédération
addiction sur la prise en charge des
addictions et je les remercie d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
j'agrandis que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat
je rappelle que le bureau de notre
commission a décidé de ne plus se saisir
pour ravi du budget de la mildeka tout
en préservant une veille attentive sur
ce sujet des addictions veille confié à
notre collègue Chantal de Seine
l'audition de ce matin a pour objet de
faire le point sur l'évolution des
pratiques en matière de conduite
addictive mais aussi de nous éclairer
sur la nécessaire adaptation des outils
de prévention et de prise en charge
cette audition intervient sur fond de
crise structurelle de notre système de
santé et plus particulièrement de notre
système de santé mentale alors que les
difficultés croissent notamment chez les
adolescents et les jeunes adultes et je
vais tout d'abord donner la parole à
Madame citoyenne
il doit nous quitter à 11 heures voilà
donc
merci beaucoup madame le présidente
monsieur madame les sénatrice monsieur
les sénateurs donc merci beaucoup déjà
de nous avoir convié ce matin pour ce
temps d'échange avec vous sur un sujet
comme vous le doutez qui nous tient
beaucoup à cœur qui est celui de la
politique donc de lutte contre les
drogues et les conduites addictives que
qui est une politique qui concerne un
grand nombre d'acteurs au sein du
gouvernement et au-delà du gouvernement
des acteurs publics sur chaque
territoire d'acteurs associatifs et
acteurs privés qui tous concours à cette
mobilisation contre les conduites
addictives donc si vous me le permettez
je ne laisserai peut-être en quelques
mots des quelques éléments de bilan sur
la mise en oeuvre de cette politique au
cours des dernières années et mettre en
mettant aussi l'accent sur les sujets
qui nous tiennent le plus à coeur qui
sont les priorités du gouvernement en ce
début d'année 2023 et bien sûr je serai
à disposition pour répondre à toutes vos
interrogations sur ce sujet qui est
assez vaste et qui implique à la fois de
nombreux produits de nombreux publics
cibles mais aussi de nombreuses
préoccupations de politiques publiques
donc peut-être quelques mots de bilan
alors si j'évoque un bilan c'est parce
que nous arrivons au terme d'un exercice
de programmation gouvernementale qui
était le plan national de mobilisation
contre les addictions
2018-2022 et qui a permis déjà
d'accentuer les efforts des pouvoirs
publics dans ce domaine de la lutte
contre les conduites addictives et qui
nous a permis d'atteindre aussi un
certain nombre de résultats qui
traduisent par des évolutions positives
d'un certain nombre de consommation et
que pourra vous présenter Julien Morel
Darleux par la suite alors quels sont
les événements marquants de ces
dernières années qui se traduisent aussi
par quelques résultats en ce début 2023
c'est d'abord une meilleure information
de la population sur les risques liés un
certain nombre d'usages
à ma formation sur les risques liés à la
consommation de tabac je commence par un
tabac puisque il s'agit en termes de
morbi mortalité du principal défi qui
continue à se poser à nous puisqu'il y a
encore plus de 70 000 morts par an liés
à la consommation de tabac à un nombre
considérable de pathologies liés à ce
produit donc cela reste vraiment notre
priorité principale en termes de si on
le prend sous l'angle la morbi mortalité
de comme vous le savez des une politique
désormais inscrite dans la durée a été
déployée au cours des années des
dernières années c'est un carnet dans
des programmes nationales de lutte
contre le tabagisme de deux exercices
ont déjà pu être conduits un troisième
est en cours de préparation et pourra
être annoncé par le gouvernement au
cours des prochaines semaines et c'est
traduit par une mobilisation
concomitante d'un certain nombre de
leviers leviers du prix le paquet neutre
mais aussi tout un
effort porté sur ce qu'on appelle la
dénormalisation du tabac dans notre
société donc pour faire apparaître à la
plus clairement aux yeux de la
population les risques liés à cette sub
alors peut-être pour juste citer
quelques opérations emblématiques qui
ont pu être reconduites et en renforcée
ce sont les opérations dites moi sans
tabac qui est pilotée par santé publique
France qu'il apporte un message très
clair sur
l'avantage de cesser la con de la
consommation de tabac avantage en terme
de santé avantage en termes de qualité
de vie mais aussi désormais de pouvoir
d'achat puisque c'est une préoccupation
pour bien sûr l'ensemble des citoyens
mais on sait qu'un fumeur le fume
quelqu'un qui consomme un paquet par
exemple de cigarettes par jour c'est
plus de 3000 euros dépensé pour ce
produit donc c'est aussi un gain de
pouvoir d'un gain de pouvoir d'achat de
pouvoir s'arrêter de fumer
autre information sur les risques qui
ont pu être conduites c'est sur l'alcool
je cite ce produit en deuxième puisque
c'est plus de 40 000 morts par an on a
là aussi beaucoup de risques non
seulement sanitaires mais aussi sociaux
associés à ce produit et j'y reviendrai
sur l'importance de l'alcool dans
l'ensemble des phénomènes de violence
dans notre pays mais ce qui a été
notamment fait au cours des dernières
années c'est le déploiement là aussi de
campagne d'information sur les risques
liés à la consommation d'alcool
notamment pour faire porter à
connaissance des Français ce qu'on
appelle les repères de consommation à
moindre risque pas plus de divers
d'alcool par semaine donc pas plus de
deux verres par jour et pas tous les
jours puisque on sait qu'on a quand même
une des risques qui sont de moindres en
pleurs si on est en dessous de ses
repères or on a encore un quart de la
population française qui par ses usages
se situe au-dessus de ces repères de
consommation à moins de risques d'où
l'importance de les porter à la
connaissance du public donc cela aussi
sous ces traduit par des campagnes
mener sous l'égide de santé publique
France
troisième produit le cannabis donc nous
avons dans notre pays encore 900 000
usagers quotidiens de cannabis donc en
termes de diffusion dans la population
là encore c'est un une préoccupation
majeure pour le gouvernement
les risques liés à l'usage de cannabis
sont de mieux en mieux documentés par la
littérature scientifique on sait en
particulier à quel point il s'agit d'une
bombe pour le cerveau des plus jeunes et
quand je dis des plus jeunes je parle
des jeunes jusqu'à 25 ans puisqu'on a un
phénomène de maturation cérébrale
jusqu'à peu près cet âge-là donc on ne
parle pas que des mineurs on parle bien
des des enfants des adolescents et des
jeunes majeurs et on sait désormais les
faits du cannabis sur ses cerveaux ça se
traduit par des troubles notamment de la
concentration de la mémoire de
l'attention avec un impact avéré sur la
réussite scolaire et l'insertion sociale
et professionnelle ultérieure donc par
exemple l'Inserm ma document a suivi des
cordes de jeunes entre ceux qui avaient
eu un usage précoce et un usage régulier
sans être très intense de cannabis ceux
qui n'en n'avait pas eu et on voit un
vrai décrochage à mesurer à bac + 3
entre ces deux ces deux groupes tels que
ça a été mesuré donc sous l'égide du
service d'information et du gouvernement
de série de campagnes ont pu être
diffusées en 2021 et en 2022 donc une
campagne plus axée sur la distillation
de la population générale axée sur les
risques liés au cannabis aussi en termes
de trafic on pourra y revenir une
campagne sous l'égide de santé publique
France plus destiné aux jeunes usagers
pour là aussi les aider à la
connaissance des risques et les orientés
vers des solutions de réduction de leur
consommation voire d'arrêt et enfin une
campagne sous l'égide de la sécurité
routière pour mettre aussi l'accent sur
les risques bien sûr en termes de
conduite automobile liée aux stupéfiants
alors au-delà des informations sur les
risques c'est bien sûr un aspect très
important mais qui ne suffit pas en
matière de prévention ce qui s'est
vraiment développé au cours des
dernières années c'est ce sont le les
programmes dit de renforcement des
compétences psychosociales alors
derrière ce terme se cache des choses à
la fois assez simples et assez difficile
à mettre en œuvre assez simple parce
qu'on parle de compétences essentielles
dans la pour la vie dans la société
c'est l'estime de soi savoir recours à
l'adulte savoir résister à la pression
des pères faire ses propres choix donc
c'est une série de compétences dont
l'enjeu de doter les enfants et
adolescents mais me voir même les
adultes on a aussi maintenant des
programmes plus à destination de des
adultes pour les aider à savoir
ne pas aborder des adoptés par non des
comportements à risque les comportements
à risque dont les conduites addictifs
font partie donc ce sont des programmes
déployés en milieu scolaire mais pas
seulement milieu scolaire aussi dans les
autres milieux de vie de l'enfant et de
l'adolescent d'abord de façon un peu
expérimentale vous aussi évaluer
l'efficacité de ces programmes et
désormais on arrive à un déploiement un
peu plus avancé je n'ose pas parler de
généralisation parce qu'on en est pas
encore là désormais dans chaque région
de françaises généralement dans le cadre
de partenariat entre le rectorat et
l'Agence régionale de santé on a des
établissements scolaires qui bénéficient
de ce programme de renforcement des
compétences psychosociales alors ils
sont souvent déployés avec l'aide de
d'acteurs du monde de la santé de la
prévention dont notamment fédération
addiction qui a été beaucoup à la
manœuvre sur le programme dans les
collèges Guillaume plug et qui mais
l'enjeu désormais est de bien sûr
l'intégrer dans les pratiques éducatives
ordinaires et donc de toucher aussi la
formation initiale et contenu des
enseignants et au-delà des enseignants
de la communauté éducative plus
généralement pour que cela puisse
infuser largement les pratiques
éducatives et pédagogiques du de
l'éducation nationale
je parlais d'autres milieux de vie de
l'enfant et de l'adolescent peut-être
juste pour mentionner que l'enseignement
agricole est aussi très actif sur ces
sujets et à de nombreux programmes de
renforcement des compétences
psychosociales dans son dans ses
établissements on a aussi construit des
choses dans des établissements tolkels
que lépides pour les jeunes décrocheurs
qui reprennent une formation
et on tente aussi de déployer ce type
d'approche dans tous les établissements
et services qui accueillent des jeunes
relevant de la protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse ou de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance donc le on n'est pas au bout
de ce chemin mais il est vraiment
labouré par l'ensemble des acteurs et ça
s'est traduit par une instruction
interministérielle adoptée en août 2022
notamment
toujours dans cette effort porté aux
plus jeunes en vous bénéfice des plus
jeunes peut-être mentionné la
constitution de ce qu'on appelle les
environnements protecteurs certes il
s'agit de doter chacun de des
informations sur les risques de la
liberté de choisir mais aussi de
constituer un environnement qui soit
protecteur pour lui et bien sûr en
priorité les enfants et adolescents qui
sont parmi les publics les plus
vulnérables quand on parle de conduite
addictives alors quelles sont ces
ingrédients d'environnement protecteur
c'est d'abord le respect de ce qu'on
appelle volontiers les interdits
protecteurs alors le premier d'entre eux
c'est l'interdiction de vente d'alcool
de tabac de jeux d'argent et de hasard
désormais de protoxyde d'azote au moins
de 18 ans c'est une interdiction qui
accorde largement pas respectée en
France les chiffres quand on fait des
enquêtes clients mystères sont assez
dramatiques puisqu'on a plus de 9
enfants sur 10 qui disent n'avoir aucun
une difficulté à s'approvisionner auprès
des débutants de boissons de tabac de
jeux d'argent et de hasard
on a plus de plus de 10% des buralistes
qui vendent sans sourciller à des
enfants de 12 ans dans les enquêtes
clients mystères alors que normalement
l'exigence une pièce d'identité est
inscrite dans la loi on a encore trop
peu de contrôle trop peu de sanctions et
notamment des sanctions aussi qui
seraient connues et qui pour avoir un
effet dissuasif donc c'est un effort
continu là encore on a fait beaucoup de
choses en matière de formation de
débutant de campagne de sensibilisation
en s'appuyant aussi sur les têtes de
pont que sont par exemple l'humili la
Fédération du commerce et la
distribution la Confédération des
buralistes etc mais on sent on voit
malheureusement que ces opérations ne
suffisent pas elles seules est-ce qu'il
faut désormais c'est aussi mobiliser les
forces de sécurité intérieure poli
gendarmerie pour mener des contrôles les
polices municipales sur le tabac et jeux
d'argent et de hasard puisqu'ils ont ils
sont fiabilité à le faire en la matière
la justice pour qu'elle puisse prononcer
des sanctions et les faire connaître
donc c'est vraiment un sujet auquel on
tient beaucoup parce qu'on a des preuves
scient selon laquelle réduire
l'accessibilité des produits pour les
mineurs c'est efficace en matière de de
réduction des consommations il peut
toujours y avoir des phénomènes de
contournement envoyer un ami prendre les
produits mis à disposition par les
parents mais malgré tout tant que cette
interdit n'est pas respecté on a un
angle mort dans notre politique publique
autre interdit auquel on tient beaucoup
c'est aussi faire respecter toutes les
règles relatives à la publicité la
publicité si elle est déployée
massivement c'est parce qu'elle a un
impact sur les consommations c'est une
incitation à consommer dont sont
victimes en particulier les plus jeunes
on a des un corpus législatif qui
existent qui est certes ça peut faire
flexible mais qui a quand même le mérite
d'exister que je pense notamment à
l'alcool je pense aussi aux jeux
d'argent et de hasard on a de une
nouvelle règle réglementation qui est
toute récente de 2020 l'enjeu c'est de
faire respecter cette réglementation et
de réduire un peu le matraquage
promotionnel dans son victime les
enfants adolescents mais aussi jeunes
adultes
et on voit bien à quel point c'est ces
stratégies cibles c'est plus jeune pour
recruter là de nouveaux consommateurs
l'environnement protecteur c'est aussi
la sensibilisation des adultes de tous
les adultes qui entourent les enfants
alors les parents en premier lieu d'où
aussi l'importance de l'information sur
les risques il faut que les parents
sachent par exemple ce les risques liés
à la consommation de cannabis il est
leurs adolescents le font mais aussi
parce qu'ils ont un rôle
primordial à jouer on a encore en France
une initiation qui se fait à certains
produits trop souvent en famille et là
il y a deux produits un peu phares
malheureusement la matière c'est
l'alcool premièrement on a encore 44%
des enfants de 6e qui ont déjà goûté de
l'alcool en sixième c'est pas avec les
copains c'est dans le cercle familial
donc ce sont généralement à l'occasion
de faire de famille parfois sous le
couvert d'éducation goût mais on a
encore des pratiques familiales qui qui
conduisent à une initiation beaucoup
trop précoce en matière d'alcool et on
se situe de très loin par rapport à tous
les autres pays européens en la matière
autre produit ce sont les jeux d'argent
et de hasard là aussi sans penser à mal
souvent initiation se fait des mineurs
se fait en compagnie des parents on va
acheter un jeu de grattage dans un point
de vente Française des jeux on fait des
paris sportifs ensemble en ligne devant
le match du jour mais là encore on sait
que ces initiations trop précoces ont
des impacts ensuite sur les conduites
addictives des jeunes devenus adultes
donc là encore des messages importants à
faire passer sur le rôle de chacun et
sur la nécessaire mobilisation des
adultes on rêve qu'un jour dans la queue
dans un buraliste les adultes ces meufs
lorsque le buraliste vend un paquet de
tabac un mineur et puisque cette
tolérance sociale à la vente aux mineurs
elle aussi baisse
l'environnement protecteur ça vaut pour
les enfants adolescents ça vaut aussi
dans d'autres milieux de vie et donc ce
sont aussi des des orientations que nous
avons adoptées que nous souhaitons
renforcer au cours des prochaines années
je pense par exemple au milieu
professionnel on sait que on a longtemps
un peu penser que il y avait une
séparation entre les
usages de substances psychoactives en
milieu privé les usages en milieu
professionnel en fait non c'est deux
usages
sont liés bien sûr et on sait à la fois
les ce que ça emporte pour les
entreprises d'avoir des des salariés qui
ont des conduites addictives il y a un
vrai aussi enjeu économique de bien-être
des salariés mais on sait aussi que le
milieu professionnel lui-même a une un
rôle à jouer c'est à dire qu'on a des
milieux de vie qui en milieu
professionnel qui sont plus ou moins
protecteurs alors ça paraît un peu
théorique mais en fait je vais prendre
quelques exemples très pratiques tout ce
qui est habitude en milieu professionnel
de faire des peaux alcoolisées
que ce soit des afterwork des pots de
départ des pots pour fêter tel ou tel
succès on sait que ça pouvait aussi être
autant d'incitations à consommer donc le
message est un de faire respecter là
aussi la loi puisque la loi limite le
type d'alcool qui peut être proposé mais
aussi de d'inciter à proposer aussi des
boissons non alcoolisées vraiment
laisser le choix aussi aux personnes de
ne pas consommer d'alcool alors je parle
d'alcool mais on a aussi d'autres
milieux professionnels soumis par
exemple à de fortes exigences de
performance et on sait maintenant que la
cocaïne notamment c'est un produit que
je n'ai pas encore évoqué mais se
diffuse en France
l'offre de cocaïne est très abondante
d'où une forte mobilisation des services
de l'ordre on pourra en reparler mais on
a aussi des usages qui sont en
augmentation alors ils sont encore sans
commune mesure avec ceux du cannabis si
on reste dans le domaine des stupé enfin
des drogues illicites mais l'usage
augmente ça nous préoccupe énormément et
on dépasse désormais les milieux un peu
classiques
traditionnels auxquels on pense on
pensait au trader les milieux de la pub
enfin c'est des images un peu
caricaturales mais on est désormais
confronté notamment dans certains
milieux professionnels à des usages
croissants de cocaïne alors quelques
exemples juste mais c'est pas du tout
exclusif et c'est certainement pas pour
les stigmatiser on sait que dans le
milieu de la restauration de
l'hôtellerie on a ce type d'usage qui se
développe avec des incitations c'est à
la consommation pour les plus jeunes
salariés de ce secteur je pense aussi à
des milieux comme les marins pêcheurs
des métiers souvent très durs le BTP ou
la cocaïne est prise aussi pour ses
effets
perçus comme aidants à la performance
donc voilà je suis très rapidement ce
milieu professionnel un dernier milieu
de vie et j'en finirai là ce panorama
sur les milieux de vie c'est celui des
milieu de vie étudiants ou une semble
aussi qu'il y a beaucoup de choses à
faire donc nous avons lancé une démarche
avec le ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur pour inciter les
établissements de l'enseignement
supérieur université grandes écoles à là
aussi être conscient
de la manière dont ce l'environnement
dans lequel évolue les étudiants et plus
ou moins incitatif ou protecteur
vis-à-vis des conduites addictives alors
quand on parle d'étudiants on pense
souvent juste au milieu festif il est
certes important donc tout ce qui est
prévention et réduits en milieu festifs
cela reste une partie importante de
notre politique publique mais au-delà du
de la vie festive il y a aussi tout ce
qui se passe sur les campus dans les
dans les logements étudiants dans la vie
associative les clubs sportifs les clubs
de loisirs les associations multiples
qui existent sur un campus où là encore
on il est important que les adultes
enfin les adultes ils sont tous adultes
à Sage là mais en tout cas les
encadrants et un discours public et un
discours clair vis-à-vis des étudiants
qu'il n'y ait pas d'incitation à
consommer et au contraire qu'il y ait
des facteurs protecteurs pour ces jeunes
adultes dont nous avons vu tout à
l'heure la vulnérabilité donc ça peut
passer par des espaces sans tabac on a
des universités qui déploient désormais
ce genre d'approche un discours clair
sur l'alcool aussi je pense le temps que
les dirigeants des des universités des
grandes écoles ne mettent pas de fin à
cette idée selon lequel les
consommations massives d'alcool ça fait
partie d'un rythme initiatique d'un
passage obligé il faut que jeunesse se
fasse tant qu'on aura ce genre de
discours porté par les encadrants dans
les universités on aura du mal à
progresser et
ça passe aussi par une sensibilisation
des salariés de tous ces établissements
d'enseignements supérieurs pour que eux
aussi puissent profiter d'un
environnement plus protecteur
peut-être juste deux trois mentions pour
finir et ensuite je répondrai bien sûr à
pendant la suite de la discussion à vos
interrogations peut-être pour mentionner
l'importance aussi de la réduction des
risques qui est donc une approche qui
permet de pour ceux qui consomment des
produits quels qu'ils soient alcool
drogues illicit de réduire les risques
associés à ces consommations donc on a
là aussi une politique qui s'est
poursuivie au cours des dernières années
qui a cherché à amplifier ses démarches
depuis la loi de 2016 la réduction des
risques est clairement inscrit dans la
loi avec tout ce que cela implique en
terme de reconnaissance de la légitimité
de cette politique de protection des
intervenants de matière de réduction des
risques en développement de nouveaux
outils alors il y a un exemple qui est
souvent emblématique dans le débat
public mais qui ne résume pas à lui seul
et j'insiste vraiment là-dessus
l'approche réduction des risques c'est
ce qu'on appelait les salles de
consommation à moins de risques
désormais halte son addiction
au cours des dernières années donc on a
pu conduire ces deux expérimentations à
Paris à Strasbourg sur tous les évalués
avec un programme ambi des marchands
d'évaluation qui a mis en évidence
l'efficacité de ce type de dispositif et
comme vous le savez bien nous sommes
désormais confrontés au défi de
stabilisation de du dispositifs
notamment à Paris mais aussi d'ouverture
éventuellement de nouvelles elles se
sont addictions sur les territoires ou
ses ouvertures sont justifiées lorsqu'il
y a des scènes ouvertes de consommation
lorsqu'il y a aussi une alliance des
acteurs locaux pour porter ce type de
dispositif mais c'est un dispositif dans
une palette d'outils donc la réduction
des risques ce n'est pas que ça c'est
aussi des démarches qui se construisent
dans beaucoup de dispositifs je pense
notamment à tout ce qui est centre
d'hébergement par exemple tous les
établissements et services de du secteur
de l'accueil hébergement insertion là
aussi c'est important de savoir comment
accompagner les
usagers de substances psychoactives pour
réduire les risques c'est aussi la
réduction des risques en milieu
là encore quand on a des grands
événements festifs il faut savoir
intervenir pour réduire les risques
associés
pardon j'avais un dernier point que je
voulais évoquer oui alors bien sûr c'est
la lutte contre les trafics mais qui
s'est renforcé depuis 2019 avec un
premier plan national de lutte contre
les trafics et un renouvellement un
approfondissement de cet exercice qui
est prévu pour 2023 donc là aussi c'est
une mobilisation très massive des forces
de sécurité intérieure police
gendarmerie les douanes aussi qui sont
très impliqués dans cette politique
toute la chaîne pénale pour avoir une
accent déterminée à la fois sur la
criminalité organisée les grosses têtes
de pont en matière de trafic mais aussi
le trafic du quotidien parce que cette
sécurité au quotidien c'est une
préoccupation aussi première du
gouvernement qui se traduit notamment
par toutes ces efforts portés sur le
démantèlement des points de Deal et
dernière chose mais qui n'est pas la
moindre moins importante c'est le
renforcement des dynamiques
territoriales en matière lutte contre
les addictions il a eu beaucoup
d'évolution au cours des dernières
années et notre ambition c'est de les
renforcer alors premièrement au niveau
des des acteurs de l'État au niveau
local je pense aux préfectures qui sont
nos relais de la Milka au niveau local
qui ont écrit des feuilles de route
régionale en 2019 alors certes c'était
un premier exercice très perfectible
mais il a traduit la mobilisation
interministérielle des acteurs au niveau
des régions et d'un département
ce sont aussi les agences régionales de
santé qui se sont vus dotés de moyens
significativement plus élevés au cours
des dernières années grâce au Front
national de lutte contre les addictions
donc les agences régionales de santé ont
des crédits ont des politiques désormais
stabilisées au niveau régional pour
mener des actions ambitieuses en matière
de prévention et d'accompagnement et de
réduction des risques dans le domaine de
la lutte contre les conduites addictives
et c'est enfin le se sont enfin les
collectivités locales qui sont qui ont
vraiment
contribué de plus en plus à cette
politique vous le savez peut-être la
mille décale lance depuis 2018 des
appels à projets d'inacionaux à
destination des communes et
intercommunalités on a un succès
grandissant avec ses appels à projet
nous en réjouissons vraiment on a
désormais à chaque appel à projet plus
d'une centaine de candidatures de
dossiers déposés ce qui nous a permis de
conclure au cours des dernières années
50 une cinquantaine de partenariats avec
des communes et intercommunalités de
toutes tailles sur l'ensemble du
territoire en métropole ou en outre-mer
avec des projets assez divers parce que
ce qui nous semblait essentiel c'est de
respecter l'orientation politique donné
par l'élu le maire ses adjoints certains
privilégie une approche autour de
l'accompagnement de des familles la
prévention telle plus jeune âge d'autres
souhaitent mettre l'accent aussi sur
l'application de la loi qui reste un
sujet très important comme je le disais
tout à l'heure sur sur aussi la
responsabilisation des débutants par
exemple donc on a des projets
avec des intonations toutes les nuances
mais tout sont le mérite d'être portés
par les lu local d'être de mobiliser
l'ensemble des services de la commune
puisque il ne sait pas seulement un
sujet sanitaire comme vous le savez
c'est un sujet qui implique beaucoup
plus largement
les services communaux on a aussi des
projets qui se déroulent à destination
des agents des communes parce que comme
je le disais ça coûte un sujet qui
concerne aussi le maire en tant
qu'employeur et qui nous permettent
vraiment d'avoir des dynamiques
territoriales très intéressantes et que
nous souhaitons approfondir au cours des
prochaines années je vais m'arrêter là
je vais sans doute été un peu long mais
c'était pour un panorama un peu global
et surtout je reste monsieur à
disposition pour vos questions et je
n'ai pas parlé de chiffres en termes de
pratique et de consommation puisque je
crois que c'est en cycle de l'eau
donc je laisse la parole à Monsieur
Julien Morel
oui merci Madame la présente bonjour
mesdames et messieurs je vous remercie
de cette audition
je relance le diaporama voilà donc merci
de nous accueillir aujourd'hui on était
dans la même configuration au Disney par
votre commission il y a un peu plus d'un
an à l'issue de la crise sanitaire et
donc je ne vais pas revenir sur
l'ensemble des données produites par
l'Observatoire français des drogues et
des tendances addictives en particulier
parce que nous veillons accusé ces
données à les rendre disponibles le plus
régulièrement possible et donc on a
réédité donc cette brochure drogue et
addiction chiffre clé au printemps 2022
et normalement si le poste fait bien son
travail vous avez dû le recevoir vos
collaborateurs ont dû le recevoir durant
l'été donc voilà c'est pour nous c'était
un élément important de vous transmettre
ces données qui sont actualisées sur
lesquels on pourra revenir de manière
plus générale je voulais vous présenter
aujourd'hui les derniers chiffres
d'évolution des consommations en
population adulte pour le cannabis et
pour l'ensemble des drogues illicités
des pour les adolescents à 17 ans alors
une partie de ces données ont été
publiées au mois de décembre avec
l'Agence de santé publique santé
publique France dans le cadre des
publications des résultats du Baromètre
santé 2021 pour le pour le cannabis dans
notre but tendance et une autre partie
que je vais vous présenter de manière
synthétique va être publiée au mois de
mars puisqu'on a pu réaliser j'y
reviendrai avec le soutien du ministère
des armées l'enquête escapade auprès de
23000 jeunes donc il dit une enquête au
monde la journée d'appel à la défense
23000 jeunes de 17 ans qui a été réalisé
donc en mars 2022 et
nos équipes n'ont pas ménagé leurs
efforts pour pouvoir présenter des
résultats moins d'un an après après la
réalisation de cette enquête parce que
c'est la première enquête de cette
ampleur en population adolescente après
la crise sanitaire il me semblait
important avec les chiffres d'aventure
2017 de comprendre disponible au plus au
grand public des sites publics et
professionnels du champ le plus tôt
possible et un peu en avant-première est
sous embargo pour vous aujourd'hui alors
je ne reviens pas sur les missions de
l'omdt que vous connaissez simplement un
élément quand même marquant pour nous
qui retrace la volonté des membres du
groupement intervie de noter notre
changement de permettre d'action depuis
2020 avec la privatisation de de la
Française des jeux et la création
d'autorité nationale des jeux il a été
décidé que l'observateur français drogue
et des toxicomanies voyez son champ
d'observation élargie avec un
renforcement il faut le noter aussi pour
la commission des affaires sociales qui
nous auditionnait chaque année donc elle
renforcement de nos moyens à la fois
d'observation et nos moyens humains
puisque en tous entre ce transfert de
renforcement des moyens qui accordaient
par le
pouvoir public on a plus trois postes
sur sur trois ans ce qui est ce qui
n'est pas anodin pour l'équipe de 30
personnes je vous laisse faire
l'augmentation le pourcentage
directement
donc voilà donc ça c'est un point
important donc on a profité de ce
changement de ce changement de
périmètre d'action pour aussi faire
évoluer cette occasion à nos
localisation de nos 25 ans d'activités
faire évoluer notre logo et surtout
notre nom et donc nous appelons toujours
au FDT en abréviation mais c'est
l'observateur français des drogues des
tendances addictives afin de couvrir
l'ensemble du champ le terme tendance
est important pour nous en tant
qu'observatoire puisque ce qui fait
aussi la force de notre dispositif c'est
d'être régulièrement répété et de
pouvoir mesurer dans le temps les
évolutions comme je vais vous le montrer
alors juste un point de rappel mais
maintenant je pense que chacun d'entre
vous maîtrise ses données mais on va
plus parler effectivement
d'expérimentation c'est à dire le fait
d'avoir
une pratique comme le jeu agent du
hasard une fois dans la vie ou avoir
consommé un produit une fois dans sa vie
en tant qu'expérimentation et on est
expérimentateur toute sa vie ça permet
de savoir finalement comment un produit
une pratique est diffusé dans notre pays
mais ce qui va nous intéresser est-ce
que je vais vous présenter aujourd'hui
c'est d'abord effectivement ce qu'on
appelle les usages dans l'année les
usages actuels c'est-à-dire les
personnes qui ont eu cette pratique ou
ce comportement ou cette consommation
dans l'année qui qui s'est écoulé qui
s'est avant avant l'enquête et plus
spécifiquement donc on ressait à la
focale sur l'usage récent c'est à dire
l'usage dans le mois et après l'usage
régulier c'est quand il y a 10 fois cet
usage dans le mois voilà je voulais
juste rappeler ces éléments avant de
vous montrer quelques pour donner
quelques données
alors sur l'évolution donc des
usages de cannabis en population adulte
en France
on a donc c'est une publication qu'on a
fait accent et public France donc en
décembre 2022 donc c'est le résultat du
Baromètre santé 2021 qui a permis
d'interroger près de 23000 personnes
d'adultes donc de 18 à 64 ans pour les
usagers de drogue illicite ce que l'on
note dans cette évolution c'est que
alors on n'a pas remis la cour parce
qu'elle elle continue à progresser la
courbe de l'expérimentation puisque
comme je le disais on est
expérimentateur toute sa vie donc on a
une génération vieillissante de
d'exploiter de kalibi on est aujourd'hui
un peu moins de la moitié des 18-64 ans
qui ont déjà été le cannabis donc c'est
c'est une légère hausse par rapport à
l'analyse précédente qui avait été faite
avec l'incendie drogue illicite mais par
contre et je pense c'est un des éléments
importants que l'on voit donc sur les
trois dernières les trois derniers
points de la comme vous le voyez on a
donc 2017 qui est notre année de
référence avant la crise sanitaire et
puis avec son public France il y a eu
deux mesures en 2020 donc pendant la
crise sanitaire et en 2021 des usages de
cannabis donc on voit en fait nous on a
souhaité dans ce numéro de tendance
faire une comparaison
2017-2021 c'est-à-dire sur sur cinq
années et on voit que l'usage dans
l'année est resté stable aux alentours
de d'un peu plus de 10% d'ici 8% des des
adultes qui ont consommé du cannabis
dans l'année mais par contre les usages
au cours du moins et les yeux
irréguliers c'est à dire des fois par
mois sont en baisse l'usage quotidien et
lui aussi en baisse chez les adultes
donc on a un deux éléments marquants
c'est qu'on a toujours une prédominance
masculine dans les usages ça c'est d'un
avariant et le deuxièmement le deuxième
point et ça je pense c'est un élément
important qu'on a qu'on a souligné dans
le dans le tendance c'est qu'on a en
fait un vieillissement des usagers
pour avoir un exemple par classe d'âge
c'est la première fois que j'ai 18 24
ans le nombre d'expérimentateurs et est
en baisse par rapport donc aux années
précédentes et donc en fait on a une
évolution
qui est qui est finalement qui va se
traduire et on va le voir après sur les
enquêtes qu'on a fait en population
adolescente c'est à dire que finalement
le c'est consommation de cannabis dans
notre pays sont portés plus parler
25-45 ans que ne le sont parlé 18 18 24
ans aujourd'hui avec en particulier je
me permets de souligner ce point puisque
c'est un élément qui est
qui est marquant même si les chiffres
sont sont assez faibles mais on a une
augmentation des usages c'est donc des
usages dans l'année chez les 59 55 64
ans donc voilà ça reste extrêmement
minime mais c'est des évolutions on voit
donc cette notion de vieillissement des
usages qui se traduit de manière
continue c'est un mouvement de qui se
traduit depuis plusieurs années alors
deuxième élément qui que vous
retrouverez dans dans ce numéro et qui
je pense intéressera directement votre
commission c'est on a pu publier
donc une évolution donc des
usages par région territoriale la taille
de l'échantillon du barreau de santé
presque ces évolutions un élément
extrêmement important dans les
discussions qu'on a pu avoir de santé
publique France et qui est attendu je
pense pas pas par vous et pas les
membres du gif c'est on a pu publier
aussi ces données
en même temps pour les territoires
ultramarins donc les la Guadeloupe la
Guyane la Martinique et la Réunion
suffisamment de
d'habitants pour pouvoir réaliser cette
enquête en population générale dans le
dans le même temps et donc c'est assez
intéressant parce que
on a une carte de France qui est assez
hétérogène on n'a pas reproduit sous
format de carte aujourd'hui mais on le
fera prochainement on a des des fiches
territoriales je vois que ça génère un
certain nombre de commentaires mais on
pourra y revenir tout à l'heure
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il y a c'est très
contrasté donc sur le sur le territoire
national c'est assez hétérogène dans
l'Hexagone il y a néanmoins contraste
Nord-Sud avec trois régions qui se
distinguent sur des usages qui sont plus
importants qui sont la nouvelle
Aquitaine l'Occitanie et la Provence à
côte d'Azur
donc c'est c'est un élément qui qui est
à noter l'autre élément qui est à noter
donc c'est les données qui apparaissent
en rouge lorsqu'il y a une des
usages qui sont plus importants avec le
la moyenne nationale l'autre élément
important à retenir en la matière c'est
que les finalement les les la diffusion
l'exploitation du cannabis dans les
territoires ultramarins et moins
importantes on est vous voyez les la
première colonne qu'il est conne de
l'exploitation est en bleu pour ces pour
ces quatre territoires mais on a par
contre dans les usages de l'année
finalement des niveaux d'usage qui sont
pas significativement différents de ceux
de la de la du territoire hexagonal et
donc on a finalement un produit qui est
moins diffusé mais qui reste consommé
par donc une frange de la population de
manière similaire à ce que l'on a sur le
territoire hexagonal voilà les premiers
éléments on pourrait revenir bien
évidemment tout à l'heure et donc je
vous présente quelques éléments donc sur
l'enquête sur la santé des consommations
lors journée d'appel à la défense est-ce
qu'il y a pas donc aujourd'hui je me
corrige d'ailleurs la journée défense
citoyenneté donc c'est un partenariat
qu'on a depuis 20 ans maintenant un peu
plus de 20 ans avec le ministère des
armées la direction du service national
et la jeunesse qui nous permet
d'interroger c'est donc ça a été mis en
œuvre au moment de la création de l'OFDT
avec le soutien de la Ville décale à
l'époque enfin la milte à l'époque qui
permet d'interroger toute une classe
d'âge donc de manière régulière et donc
c'était le 10ème exercice depuis 2000 le
premier exercice depuis 2017 comme je je
l'évoquais donc ça permet une enquête
qui reprendative des consommations chez
les jeunes Français à 17 ans cette
enquête elle a un questionnaire qui est
stabilisé dans le temps et qui permet
d'interroger à la fois la question des
usages de produits comme j'ai évoqué
mais également les depuis 2011 on a des
questions sur les jeux d'argent et de
hasard et c'est un élément sur lequel je
voyais insister aujourd'hui on a aussi
un mode tout un module de questions sur
la santé physique et mentale des jeunes
et je pense que c'est un des points que
que l'on va voir ensemble
alors l'enquête a eu lieu en mars 2022
sur une semaine la mission des armées a
fait tous ses efforts pour nous
permettre de convoquer près de 25000
jeunes sur une semaine sur le territoire
hexagonal on va réaliser dans les
territoires ultramarins cette enquête
puisque jusqu'à lors on irait réaliser
en même temps sur en dans l'Hexagone et
sur les tramarins compte tenu des délais
de de convocation sur une semaine on ne
pouvait pas le réaliser dans les
outre-mer l'année dernière donc on va le
faire cette année avec la direction du
service national et de la jeunesse donc
on aura un petit décalage sur les
données mais on pourra continuer à avoir
cette enquête sur l'ensemble du
territoire national en tout on a 2430 de
17 ans qui ont répondu à cette
à cette enquête avec le département et
le sexe ronciné je le dis c'est
important pour les analystères que l'on
fera ensuite et je le disais en
introduction c'est la première enquête
de cette ampleur que l'on a réalisé
auprès de la population adolescente
alors quelques données générales sur ces
premiers résultats que l'on est toujours
en cours de de finalisation et avant de
les valoriser au mois de au mois de mars
la première donnée importante et je
reviendrai de manière plus détaillée
juste après c'est la baisse très forte
du tabagisme je vous avais présenté en
2021 les résultats de l'enquête en
classe en troisième qui montrait une
très forte baisse déjà de chez de 3e de
ces
consommations de tabac
cette baisse s'accentue donc on perd
quasiment 10 points de pourcentage entre
2017 et 2022 puisqu'on est aujourd'hui à
15,6% des jeunes de 17 ans se déclarant
fumeur quotidien ils étaient donc 25% il
y a il y a 5 ans
par contre et c'est un élément sur
lequel on va continuer à travailler avec
tout un module sur le sujet c'est sur la
question de l'usage de la e-cigarette
puisque là on a un quasi par contre
doublement des usages au cours du mois
un des points de vigilance concernant la
cigarettes c'est c'est en fait lorsqu'on
interroge les jeunes ils ont parfois du
mal à dire ce qu'il y a comme E-liquide
dans le récit Garette ce qui peut
d'ailleurs générer on l'avait vu ces
dernières années aussi des des
incidences sanitaires lorsqu'il y avait
des liquides avec des nouveaux produits
de synthèse qui circulaient en milieu
scolaire
donc pour être très clair l'ensemble des
usages déclarés est en baisse sur que ce
soit sur les produits de site et
illicites sur l'alcool donc j'ai pris
j'ai pris juste ces données sur l'usage
récent c'est à dire l'usage dans le mois
donc on a aussi une baisse quasiment de
8 points des usages sur le cannabis
l'usager c'est dire 10 fois par mois on
a une baisse quasiment par deux on a
posé pour la première fois une question
sur l'usage du CBD qui a fait l'objet de
nombreux débats et qui montre qu'on a
par contre un niveau de diffusion qui
est important un 14 %
qui est dans le visage au cours du mois
et sur les autres produits illicites on
a une baisse et le donc on passe de 6,8
à 3,9%
. donc ça c'est un premier point juste
un petit focus en la matière sur le
tabac puisque c'est quand même le
résultat le plus marquant on a depuis
qu'on a mis en place l'enquête une
baisse de 25 points des usages de tabac
quotidien
depuis 2000 donc on était à 41% en 2000
on est à 16% aujourd'hui 9 fois en moins
donc je disais tout à l'heure entre 2016
et 2022 et l'exploitation du tabac dans
la ville donc l'expérimentation du tabac
finalement est aussi en baisse un
quasiment 30 points en entre 2000 et
2022 donc c'est très clairement un effet
de génération qui est qui fait suite à
un certain nombre d'interdictions qu'on
peut être mis en oeuvre c'est depuis le
milieu des années 2000 sur
l'interdiction de vente aux mineurs
l'interdiction de fumer dans les lieux
publics le paquet neutre c'est tous ces
éléments en fait jouent sur
l'accessibilité à un produit et je
permet de rebondir sur ce qu'il disait
tous ces varices voyants sur finalement
ces interdits protecteurs on a là
effectivement un effet marquant
il y a néanmoins un bémol dans à tous
ces chiffres et je pense que c'est un
élément de réflexion sur lequel nous
allons travailler dans l'analyse de ces
résultats et pour une fois dans le dans
le numéro de tendance que nous
publierons au mois de mars on aura un
focus plus important que les années
précédentes sur le sujet c'est sur la
dégradation de tous les indicateurs de
santé donc je vous disais depuis 2000 la
même manière qu'on pose les mêmes
questions sur les usages on a un module
sur le sur les
à la fois la santé physique et la santé
psychique des adolescents avec des
questions qui sont standardisées qui
sont posées dans dans des questions dans
des enquêtes en population générale
si la consommation médicament est
globalement comparable à celle de 2017
on a des jeunes qui
perçoivent leur santé comme étant
mauvaise donc une augmentation de d'un
peu plus de points on va dire ils sont
en leur demande leur taille et leur foi
donc ça nous permet de mesurer
l'IMC donc ça permet de voir qu'on a en
fait une augmentation du surpoid de
l'obésité avec un marqueur plus
important sur le sur l'obésité donc on
passe effectivement là aussi un peu plus
de points et demi en 5 ans on a un
centre de question qui permet de mesurer
donc les la question des
du risque de dépression légère au sévère
là aussi on a une hausse de 10 points
des indicateurs qui nous sont transmis
par les jeunes interrogés et enfin on a
une forte hausse des pensées suicidaires
mais aussi des tentatives de suicide
déclarées voilà c'est des questions qui
sont qui marquent de manière importante
donc une dégradation des indicateurs de
santé depuis 5 ans une évolution qui est
l'inverse à la à celle de la des usages
donc à la différence
des adultes qui qui ont pu déjà
expérimenter un produit ces jeunes n'ont
pas n'ont pas eu de sans doute de
d'opportunités pendant la crise
sanitaire en particulier pendant les
périodes de confinement de d'accéder à
d'autres modes de sociabilité qui leur
qui aurait pu peut-être découvrir des
produits mais aussi avoir des activités
qui sont qui leur permettraient de
lutter contre ces
risques de dépression légère ou sévère
ces pensées suicidaires et cette
perception globale d'une santé mauvaise
donc il y a je le pense et c'est enfin
nous pensons c'est un élément de
vigilance de et d'attention mais je
pense que Jean-Michel de Lille rebondira
sur ce point et c'est un point également
souligné par les citoyens c'est un point
de vigilance à avoir pour pour nos
jeunes et donc dernier point donc voilà
nous allons publier donc début mars ces
résultats nous avons un focus spécifique
sur les jeux d'argent et de hasard
publiés au printemps au plus tard elle
était 2023 ainsi que des régionales
voilà et puis donc les deux autres
publications qui sont déjà qui sont déjà
en ligne sont sur cette diapositive
voilà je vous remercie pour votre
attention
faire
et ensuite on passera aux questions nous
avons beaucoup de questions
merci madame la Présidente pour votre
invitation mesdames messieurs je vous
remercie également parce qu'en
introduction vous avez évoqué la crise
qui heurte actuellement tout le système
de santé particulièrement le système de
santé mentale alors j'y suis sensible en
tant que psychiatre je suis encore plus
sensible en tant que psychiatre exerçant
dans le secteur médico-social puisque la
crise également massive y compris sous
forme de crise des ressources humaines
alors néanmoins pour compléter la ce qui
vient d'être dit par nos amis aussi bien
en termes de cadrage gouvernemental
avait le plan national qu'avec les
l'évolution des des données auxquelles
je souscris tout à fait qui viennent
vous êtes présenté par l'omdt quels sont
quelques mots les adaptations en cours
de notre secteur dans le domaine aussi
bien de la prévention des soins que la
réduction des risques en autre secteur
je suis président de la Fédération
addiction qui regroupe environ 80% des
des établissements au niveau national
donc des dès que ça pas des centres de
soins les Carus les centres de réduction
des risques sachant que
les équipes sont des équipes
pluridisciplinaires donc ils proposent
une prise en charge
globale en matière de de prévention tout
d'abord je crois que la clé c'est ce qui
vient d'être dit actuellement et que
vous aviez évoqué en introduction c'est
à dire que dans peut-être en partie
suite à la crise sanitaire et à
l'isolement des jeunes on a en assiste à
une dégradation extrêmement sensible de
la qualité de vie et également des
indicateurs de santé mentale comme ça
vient d'être évoqué chez les chez les
adolescents alors ça c'est un problème
en soi évidemment on parlait des
conduits suicidaires c'est un problème
aussi parce que c'est évidemment un
facteur de vulnérabilité par rapport à
une entrée dans des consommations
éventuellement ensuite dans une
transition pour des conduites addictives
donc c'est un point à surveiller de très
très près qui nous incite non seulement
à continuer à promouvoir évidemment les
actions de soutien aux compétences
psychosociales car rappelait tout à
l'heure Valérie saintoyant mais aussi à
développer tous les programmes liés au
consultation jeune consommateurs j'avais
évoqué lors de la réunion de décembre à
l'Assemblée nationale qui était co-animé
d'ailleurs par le sénateur yakovelli en
présence du ministre l'importance de ces
structures de terrain qui sont répartis
sur tous les territoires qui peuvent
permettre de recevoir des jeunes qui
sont en difficulté mais des jeunes ont
difficultés au plan psychologiques au
plan social au plan familial ou le point
d'appel est peut-être une prise de
substance ou un abus un abus d'écran
mais où il importe évidemment d'essayer
de faire un bilan général de cette de
cette situation pour pour bien avancer
en termes de prise en charge il faut que
nous adaptions à l'évolution des
pratiques et des consommations alors il
y a des données on le dit pas assez
peut-être parce que les
pouvoirs publics sont responsables grâce
aux plans qui se sont succédés notamment
par rapport au tabac par rapport à
l'alcool les professionnels ont dû jouer
un rôle également mais l'ensemble de la
population je crois qu'il y a une prise
de conscience et on assiste à vraiment
un effondrement des niveaux de
consommation d'alcool par rapport aux
années 60 dans notre pays avec une
mutation complète des modes consommation
avec une réduction
des consommations quotidiennes qui
étaient celles de ma génération des
consommations de vins de 20 à table etc
et une évolution vers d'autres modes de
pratique qui posent d'autres problèmes
le tabac ça a été évoqué aussi ça a se
réduit ça continue à se réduire il y a
un ralentissement actuel mais la
tendance positive se poursuit chez les
jeunes alors en quoi ça nous concerne
c'est parce que moins il y aura de
personnes en masse dépendante de ces
produits là alcool et tabac plus les
situations les plus difficiles les plus
résistantes ceux qui vont rester
accrochés seront des personnes qui
présenteront des comorbidités et des
vulnérabilités psychologiques et
sociales c'est sûr c'est déjà évident
par rapport au tabac où il y a un
gradient social majeur c'est un facteur
majeur d'inégalités sociales c'est vrai
aussi pour l'alcool ça commence à être
pour le cannabis très très nettement et
là on voit bien que pour prendre en
charge ces personnes là il faut prendre
en charge aussi ces vulnérabilités de
l'intérêt des équipes
pluridisciplinaires et donc des
établissements comme les nôtres qui
historiquement il faut bien le dire
était quand même orienté héroïne cocaïne
etc un peu alcool vont devoir développer
ses activités auprès du tabac de
l'alcool le cannabis c'était déjà
c'était déjà le cas une autre évolution
sensible qui est évidente c'est que si
les jeunes vont moins bien et s'ils
consomment peut-être moins de cannabis
et Tabas si ce qui est bien en revanche
qui se développe c'est les
problématiques de comportement
alimentaire avec des boulimie
manifestement à dimensions addictive ça
a été évoqué là sur les les prises de
poids etc et puis également les écrans
les écrans là c'est une explosion totale
là aussi amplifiée par le confinement
très très clairement mais qui ne diminue
pas depuis qui qui se poursuit alors les
écrans c'est moins dangereux pour la
santé physique en revanche c'est pas bon
pour la santé psychique pas du tout
c'est un facteur d'isolement de
dépression de conduite suicidaire etc et
on voit en plus qu'il y a des des au
sein de ces addictions là bon les jeux
vidéo ce qui se développe le plus ce
sont de vrais addictions avec les jeux
d'argent de hasard avec la porno sur
internet etc et des dimensions qui
de l'autre côté une adaptation parce que
clairement c'était pas notre
savoir-faire de base alors peut-être que
le covid qui nous a permis de développer
des outils de vie santé nous permettra
aussi d'inventer des modalités
d'intervention qui seront peut-être plus
proches de ces usagers bien réels mais
qui sont éloignés de nous qui sont dans
un espace virtuel l'autre dimension qui
est également lié à Internet évidemment
c'est le développement contrepartie des
usages de produits de synthèse en
réinitialement dans des niches comme les
cames secteurs mais qui se développent
maintenant tout à fait en dehors de ces
niches là dans le milieu festif on pense
au catinon à 3 MMC ou également au
cannabis de synthèse mais on pense aussi
à tout ce qui est commandé sur Internet
comme produit industriels il était
évoqué tout à l'heure enfin le GBL en
l'occurrence mais pourquoi pas aussi le
protoxyde d'azote qu'on peut commander
assez facilement etc donc là aussi ça
nécessite des adaptations de notre part
et puis le dernier point que j'évoquerai
c'est en matière de réduction des
risques et d'accès aux soins ça a été
très bien évoqué par Madame saintoyant
je crois qu'il faut voir que la
difficulté aussi que nous avions
peut-être c'est que nous étions dans la
représentation des gens des structures
qui aidaient les gens vraiment à arrêter
totalement définitivement etc ça c'est
le gold standard c'est parfait c'est ce
qu'il faut arriver à faire pour la
plupart des addictions en revanche
beaucoup de d'usagers se reconnaissaient
pas dans ce produit ça n'avait pas envie
il voulait redevenir comme avant et
consommateurs maîtrisés et finalement on
se rendait compte que du coup ces
personnes-là restaient sur la touche
alors même que leur consommation
excessive souvent pour être dommageable
pour leur santé si bien qu'on a
développé des actions qui partent au
plus près des demandes des gens donc
souvent plutôt des actions de
sécurisation des consommations de
diminution des niveaux et y compris par
rapport à l'alcool et y compris dans les
centres sociaux qui étaient évoqués tout
à l'heure avec du coup la possibilité
d'élargir vraiment la palette des
personnes accueillies non seulement des
personnes dépendantes mais également des
personnes qui comme beaucoup d'autres
ports des consommations excessives sans
que ça soit nécessairement dépendante
donc ça c'est des des dimensions qui
peuvent être intéressantes qui sont
également intéressantes en termes de
messages positifs sans doute par rapport
aux jeunes qu'on peut rencontrer à
propos des écrans eux clairement ils
veulent pas arrêter
la dimension qu'on va leur proposer
c'est une dimension de réduction des
risques c'est-à-dire d'arriver peut-être
à continuer à avoir des pratiques qui
peuvent être agréables ou utiles mais
sans perdre le contrôle sans que ça les
isole sans que ça les déprime etc et
c'est ce type de message qui peut être
entendu des messages positifs comme ceux
qu'on développe actuellement on est en
janvier à propos de l'alcool avec le
drive Jeannot Harry c'est-à-dire on dit
pas aux gens à arrêter c'est
définitivement c'est une horreur c'est
le diable mais faites l'expérience
vous-même d'une suspension de modération
de vos consommations pendant le mois de
janvier pour voir où vous en êtes par
rapport à l'alcool ce qui vous permettra
ensuite d'avoir une relation plus
régulière voilà je vous remercie
merci beaucoup Nathan alors nous avons
beaucoup de questions on va faire de
salves de questions Chantal de Seine
Michel meunier Laurence Cohen Brigitte
Daniel Chassin Chantal de Seine merci
madame la Présidente merci Madame et
messieurs pour votre présentation je
vais parvenir surtout les points parce
que j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup de questions je
voudrais vous en posséder une
essentiellement c'est sur les salles de
consommation à moindre risque en
particulier celle de Paris qui nous
alerte depuis plusieurs mois et qui nous
fait part de ces difficultés à prendre
en charge
les personnes sous emprises de drogue et
qui ont besoin d'un suivi en particulier
depuis l'évacuation du square
Perceval je crois forcevale pardon
j'avais pas tout à fait les mêmes
références en octobre dernier
difficulté à apprendre en charge ces
personnes parce qu'il manque de
personnel mais parce que aussi la fille
active a augmenté alors nous avions
fondé beaucoup d'espoir sur cette
expérimentation lancée maintenant depuis
6 ans
en tout cas en ce qui me concerne
j'espérais après l'expérimentation sur
Paris et Strasbourg une extension
de ces salles de consommation à moins
touristes qu'on a entendu parler de
certains projets sur Marseille sur
Bordeaux mais qui ont avorté ou en tout
cas qui n'ont jamais vu le jour et donc
je voulais savoir quel était la
politique en la matière et si on
envisageait de développer ces salles et
puis une autre petite question et après
je laisserai ma parole à mes collègues
c'est quelle est la situation des
usagers de crack dans le nord-est
parisien en particulier depuis l'é
situation du square sportceval parce
qu'il y avait un dispositif le
dispositif assure qui permettait de les
accompagner en particulier pour ces
usagers en errance en leur proposant des
hébergements dans des chambres d'hôtel
or il savait qu'on n'a pas une offre
suffisante en hébergement et donc quel
dispositif et comment accompagner ce
public particulièrement fragile alors
après je pourrais éventuellement vous
parler de l'addiction au jeu l'addiction
alimentaire qui me préoccupe tout
particulièrement des peufs etc etc mais
voilà je veux pas griller la politesse à
mes collègues et je pense que des
questions complémentaires vous seront
posées je vous remercie merci Michel si
madame la Présidente merci pour la
présentation très complète et globale de
vos actions moi je vais aller très vite
avec un sujet dont on parlait juste
avant votre audition c'est les JO
l'organisation des JO de 2024 et je
voulais savoir en quelle manière de
quelle manière l'ami delka a été
associée parce qu'il y a des questions
qui peuvent se poser sur l'éventuelles
dérogation à la loi Evin donc on parle
bien sûr on pense bien sûr à la
consommation d'alcool dans et hors de
l'enceinte mais aussi tout ce qui est
prévention primaire affichage et on sait
que là les sponsors alcooliers et autres
marques liées à du plaisir et du
dépassement sont souvent très pervers et
très pernicieux pour des personnes
concernées par ces produits et ses
comportements addictifs donc voilà je
voulais savoir comment vous avez été
associés à la préparation des JO j'ai
une autre question c'est vous madame qui
l'avez abordé donc les aidants
l'environnement et particulièrement les
aidants des malades alcooliques sont
souvent des personnes qui souffrent
peut-être plus que parce qu'il y a un
déni dans l'alcoolisme qui est évident
et ces questions liées à aux violences
et autres sujets que vous avez abordés
je voulais voilà connaître votre
approche
d'accompagnement de ces malades est-ce
qu'il y a des actions spécifiques le
protoxyde d'azote vous l'avez aussi
mentionné je voudrais savoir quels sont
les contrôles réels qui sont faits sur
la commercialisation et la vente de ces
cartouches en grand nombre sur les sites
internet il y a des des
sites qui sont des qui sont dédiés qui
n'ont de vocations que la vente de ces
produits et je voulais là aussi que vous
nous disiez comment vous contrôlez et
avec combien d'équivalentes temps plein
vous effectuez cette mission et puis
j'avais une toute dernière question mais
je suis désolé parce que je vous ai tout
très en différé puis particulièrement
pour la présidente madame de roche je
voulais lui demander si les amandes
étaient en vente libre et si la
consommation régulière pouvait être
considérée comme une addiction
c'est un peu addictif je reconnais que
les chocolats sont un peu addictifs ils
sont en vente libre ils sont en vente
libre dans deux magasins il y a même des
distributeurs automatiques de caramande
dans la ville d'Angers pour ceux qui ont
besoin de carrément la nuit ou le
dimanche voilà
c'est Laurence Cohen
moi je trouve que Michel a été très
pertinente et c'est toujours un moment
de douceur on pensait à toi à chaque
fois donc merci ah oui c'est vrai donc
moi je vous remercie Madame et messieurs
pour pour vos présentations j'aurai un
certain nombre de questions à vous poser
concernant des phénomènes qui sont très
très à la mode je pense pas vous avoir
entendu évoquer le tabac à
sachet à sucer le sinus qui est très
très en vogue parmi parmi les jeunes
notamment sur Tik Tok et sur un certain
nombre aussi de sportifs et j'aimerais
avoir un peu votre votre évaluation du
phénomène et comment on peut travailler
d'un point de vue préventif ma seconde
question concerne les les cigarettes
électroniques les puffes on n'a pas de
recul insuffisant par rapport à la
activité à l'addiction etc j'aimerais
savoir s'il y a eu des de nouvelles
recherches qui ont été effectuées qui
nous permettent de mieux de mieux
appréhender donc ce que ça le côté
positif et le côté négatif de ses puces
et nous avions voté nous au niveau au
niveau du Sénat sur d'ailleurs c'est une
proposition de Catherine procacia de
taxer les les pubs ça a été ça a été
voté au niveau du Sénat et d'ailleurs et
je crois que ça a été enfin ça a pas été
maintenu du tout ça a été rejeté par le
gouvernement donc voilà c'est quand même
une vraie une vraie problématique
mon autre mon autre question c'est que
vous l'avez évoqué effectivement il y a
le tabac l'alcool qui sont en vente
libre mais qui ont des effets absolument
terribles sur la santé sur la santé
publique et à côté de ça il y a
effectivement le le cannabis qui lui
n'est pas êtes libre mais moi j'aimerais
quand même vous entendre sur le fait que
le le cannabis
je crois qu'on le vit tout et tous que
ce soit en zone urbanisée ou en zone
rurale ça entraîne des trafics
absolument terribles et ces sources de
violence et toutes les politiques qui
ont été menées de sécurité
d'interdiction etc ont été voués à
l'échec je pense notamment à toutes les
politiques qui ont été menées aux
États-Unis mais pas que quand j'avais
travaillé sur la question moi j'avais
j'avais été à l'initiative d'une charte
en 2012 qui avait réuni les principales
associations et les fédérations de lutte
contre les addictions et tout le monde
était arrivé à la à la constatation
qu'il fallait dépénaliser l'usage du
cannabis et je pense qu'après il y a des
évolutions sur la légalisation du
cannabis qui ent après justement le fait
de stopper ces trafics et puis de
pouvoir aussi contrôler les choses parce
que aujourd'hui on sait que le cannabis
aujourd'hui n'est plus d'oser de la même
façon qu'il pouvait l'être il y a
quelques années donc il y a aucun
contrôle donc moi je ne suis je ne suis
pas convaincu sur le fait que le fait de
de comment dirais-je de
d'accès plus sur le sécuritaire etc je
suis loin d'être convaincu que c'est le
côté positif donc j'aime j'aimerais
avoir votre votre analyse sur sur cette
question là il m'a toute dernière
question c'est que quand même on
constate que les moyens dont vous
disposez je pense la middelka le fdt etc
sont des moyens qui sont en forte
diminution au cours des années Chantal
l'a dit il a évoqué donc c'est quand
même un phénomène énorme et moi je sais
que par exemple pour pour notamment
pour suivre les trafiquants les gros
trafiquants etc il y a quand même des
moyens qui sont très très très faibles
au niveau de de la police et à tous les
niveaux donc j'aimerais aussi avoir
votre appréciation sur vos propres
moyens pour arriver à répondre à toutes
les questions à toutes les
problématiques qui vous sont demandées
merci gîte alors merci pour votre
présentation l'ami de cas a édité en
2022 un guide le maire face aux
conduites addictives alors j'ai bien
entendu qu'une gavé une cinquantaine de
partenariats et des projets divers je
voudrais savoir quel retour avez-vous de
cette publication j'ai une deuxième
question quel est le bilan après deux
années de mise en place d'amende
forfaitaire délictuel face à l'usage de
stupéfiants et j'ai une troisième
question le Mondial de football vient de
se terminer je voudrais savoir si les
chiffres en particulièrement
merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames messieurs pour votre
présentation donc nous a rappelé
effectivement que le cannabis quand même
usages quotidiens et en augmentation
bien sûr la cocaïne et votre action de
prévention alors il y a quand même dans
ce que nous avait dit
les choses un peu réconfortantes c'est à
dire que l'alcool se diminue chez les
jeunes même si l'augmente dans certaines
festivités longuement de façon massive
diminution du cannabis qui est divisé
par deux mais les troubles dépressifs
chez jeunes et développement des des
écrans donc mes questions c'est on a le
développement du protoxyde d'azote enfin
qui est arrivé en milieu rural et quel
est son développement et est-ce qu'il y
a beaucoup de recrutement
par Internet
est-ce que quels sont les produits qu'il
y a dans la cigarette électronique
est-ce que c'est nocif
et enfin
je pense que en ce qui concerne le
cannabis on se rend compte que
c'est vraiment une plaie effectivement
pour notre pays avec effectivement des
troubles de mémoire et en même temps
psychotique et je pense pas que le fait
de l'égalisation puisque dans d'autres
pays on voit que où c'est légalisé et
bien il y a encore autant au plus de
problèmes
alors je vous laisse répondre puisque
madame citoyenne doit partir assez vite
et ensuite nous aurons nous aurons
d'autres questions
merci madame la Présidente merci
beaucoup pour toutes vos questions et
observations la plupart d'entre elles
mériteraient un débat en soi donc je
regrette déjà d'avance de répondre sans
doute trop vite et peut-être et sans
doute pas de manière exhaustive donc je
vais essayer de balayer quelques
principaux sujets et je m'excuse
d'avance de devoir vous quitter ensuite
alors peut-être premièrement sur les
salles de consommation à moins de
risques la situation du crack dans le
nord-est parisien les nouvelles HSA oui
donc il y a eu évacuation du square du
fort cheval au début de l'automne par
les actions conjointes des services de
l'État avec aussi bien sûr l'aide des
des acteurs du monde sanitaire
médico-social et sociales qui qui aident
à la prise en charge des usagers de
crack comme vous le savez c'est une
problématique très complexe peut-être
juste en deux mots pour l'instant il n'y
a pas eu de reconstitution de d'un camp
d'un campement et ça c'est aussi c'est
en particulier lié à la mobilisation
très forte des forces de l'ordre à Paris
mais cela ne fonctionne que si en
parallèle on offre une prise en charge
adaptée à ces usagers de crack qu'il a
aussi est nécessite une mobilisation
conjointe de tous les services donc
c'est vraiment des efforts à la fois des
acteurs de l'État mais aussi des acteurs
sanitaires et associatifs qui
interviennent au fil de ces usagers donc
le dispositif a sort que vous évoquiez
madame la sénatrice il est poursuivi sa
montée en charge on est après de 600
places offertes il a beaucoup augmenté
tout au long de la crise sanitaire donc
voilà se pose toujours la question
est-ce que c'est suffisant ou pas
suffisant mais c'est un effort
considérable offert ainsi par les
pouvoirs publics et ses partenaires et
qui est un dispositif qui fonctionne
bien puisqu'on a une évaluation en fait
par les les Hospices Civils de Lyon qui
montrent que la prise en charge via ce
dispositif au sort a permis à 87% des
personnes accompagnées de réduire voire
d'arrêter sa consommation de crack donc
il n'y a pas de solution mais miracle en
matière de prise en charge Jésus et
craque mais il est vraiment des efforts
que je souhaite souligner de tous les
acteurs autour de cette dimension alors
oui il y a eu des impacts aussi sur la
salle de consommation moindre risque à
Paris cette salle on le sait même si
elle est ce dispositif est efficace
c'est un dispositif qu'il s'agit
toujours de conforter de poursuivre dans
la durée parce que la philative est
importante elle reste importante il y a
eu des enfin il y a des difficultés de
recrutement mais malheureusement comme
plus largement aussi dans les les
secteurs sanitaires et médico-social et
sociales donc nous veillons au maximum à
conforter ce dispositif à lui permettre
de bien fonctionner les nouvelles HSA la
politique du gouvernement c'est de
l'accompagner on a des crédits mis en
réserve à cet effet ceux qui l'enjeu
c'est de trouver des alliances
territoriales pour pouvoir le pour
autoriser
ces ouvertures dans les villes on a des
projets effectivement à Bordeaux
Marseille Lille Lyon ce projet ne sont
pas enterrés ils sont en discussion
nécessite vraiment le à la fois la
Louisa son conjointe c'est des services
de l'État mais aussi de la collectivité
locale d'implantations et des acteurs
locaux sur le sport les JO la coupe du
monde de foot c'est un effet un enjeu
important sous plusieurs dimensions
parce que il y a une association
malheureuse à notre sens parfois entre
sport et alcool les consommations à
risque d'alcool
aux abords des stades en accompagnement
des événements sportifs donc nous
travaillons avec la Délégation
interministérielle de gestion des grands
événements sportifs la digeste pour
préparer au mieux les prochaines
échéances il y a certes les JO il y a
aussi la Coupe du monde de rugby qui se
prépare avec une dizaine de villes qui
accueillent ces événements donc nous
travaillons pour effectivement faire de
la prévention et réduire les
consommations à risque aussi en régulant
les débits de boissons qui seront
concernés
aussi de lutter contre l'association là
aussi qui n'est pas que positive entre
sport et jeux d'argent et de hasard on a
un sponsoring du monde sportif important
par les opérateurs de jeux d'argent et
de hasard c'est de marier l'image des
transports du sport avec les paris
sportifs or les paris sportifs ils sont
malheureuses et conduisent certes ça
peut être une pratique récréative mais
ça devient un usage problématique pour
un certain nombre de jeunes je parle les
jeunes parce que ce sont vraiment les
publics vulnérables en priorité sur ces
usages paris sportifs un usage
problématique de paris sportifs ça peut
conduire à des problèmes financiers
importants outre la perte de contrôle
etc et qui dit problème financier peut
ensuite conduire aussi à des
comportements voire de délinquance pour
rembourser les dettes donc on a un
engrenage là qui est très problématique
et on est très préoccupé par le
développement à la fois du jeu d'argent
et de hasard qui est un secteur en
pleine croissance mais surtout par le
développement concomitant du jeu
problématique donc effectivement ce sont
des
des liens qu'il s'agit de casser ou au
moins de limiter les nouveaux produits
associés au tabac les enfin le SNU c'est
pas vraiment nouveau mais on a
effectivement un peu d'émergence en
France c'est interdit en France donc
c'est un point de vigilance les peurs
effectivement là aussi on se je parlais
tout à l'heure de matraquage des jeunes
publicitaires des jeunes typiquement
c'est un point d'entrée pour un
industrie du tabac pour toucher aussi
les les jeunes certaines peuvent ou la
plupart contiennent de la nicotine c'est
ça le produit addictif donc on sait que
ça peut être un point d'entrée dans le
tabagisme en tout cas l'addiction à la
nicotine et donc il s'agit de travailler
pour
travailler y compris bien sûr avec vous
parlementaire pour trouver les meilleurs
moyens d'encadrer ces usages
je n'ai pas le temps de plus sans doute
de faire un débat entier sur la
légalisation du cannabis tu as juste
pour appeler la position des
gouvernements qui n'est pas favorable à
ce changement de statut légal pour des
raisons principalement comme conserve
comme pragmatique c'est à dire les
objectifs d'un tel changement de statut
légal ce serait soit de réduire les
consommations et ou de réduire la
criminalité associée aux stupéfiants et
il nous semble que au terme de
l'observation des analyses étranges des
expériences étrangères alors on n'est
pas au bout de ses expériences et donc
ce sont des points d'étapes mais dans
tous les pays qui ont franchi ce pas
nous considérons qu'il n'y a pas de
réussite en termes de réduction des
consommations plutôt contraire de
banalisation du produit et
d'augmentation chez les jeunes adultes
et pas de d'amancer significative en
termes de réduction des trafics non plus
les trafiquants se déportant sur des
produits soient plus dosés soit moins
zones mais je conçois que ça mériterait
un débat à part entière
le guide du maire donc effectivement
nous sommes heureux d'avoir pu le
diffuser je peux pas vous parler des
valsons d'impact on sent juste que les
exemplaires sont bien partis donc on
espère que c'est effectivement un outil
qui sert à la fois au maire aux élus
mais aussi aux acteurs locaux on sait
que les préfectures s'en servent
beaucoup sinon leur dialogue avec les
préfectures
et le protoxyde d'azote reste
effectivement un sujet on a quand même
une loi qui a été adoptée en 2021 pour
interdire la vente aux mineurs interdire
l'avant dans un certain nombre de débits
se poseraient clairement le la question
des contrôles ne peut qu'en convenir et
comme je le disais ça me concerne
malheureusement pas que le prototype
d'azote mais aussi plus largement
interdiction de vente d'alcool de tabac
de jeux d'argent hasard au mineur et le
protoxyde d'azote et c'est vraiment un
défi pour nous qu'on aimerait pouvoir
relever
merci
vous souhaitez compléter par rapport aux
questions déjà posées de faire de l'île
peut-être
juste quelques mots en complément pour
les salles de consommation
dorénavant dénommée elle te soins
addiction
on voit bien que la situation est ça
c'est en soi une leçon est très
différente à Paris à Strasbourg
à Paris un problème de massification de
flux massif de d'une population très
très paupérisée très marginale très
visible avec des problèmes de
tranquillité publique que nous nous
retrouvons pas à Strasbourg avec une
population comparable mais en moindre en
moindre effectif une des leçons que l'on
peut tirer je crois en termes
d'adaptation en tout cas c'est une
proposition qu'on avait faite en son
temps au ministre Véran et plus
récemment c'était de plutôt que de
développer dans les villes des gros
dispositifs comme celui de de Paris
essayez de voir des dispositifs
peut-être de plus faible plus plus
faible ampleur et pourquoi pas de
dispositifs mobiles c'est ceux qui ont
été expérimentés initialement à
Barcelone à Copenhague Montréal etc qui
répondent à des besoins parce qu'ils
peuvent aller au devant d'usagers qui
sont éloignés mais en allant chez eux
dans les squats les endroits différents
sans les regrouper dans un endroit
particulier et d'autre part des
dispositifs qui peuvent évacuer si
d'aventures il y a des problèmes de
proximité donc ça va être intégré dans
la loi mais à ma connaissance il manque
des décrets d'application pour que ce
type de dispositif puisse être proposé
alors effectivement il y a différentes
villes de de France là qui ont ce type
de projet avec les difficultés qu'on
connaît en tout cas à Bordeaux pour le
moment le travail continue à Lyon aussi
à Marseille aussi mais il y a toutes les
difficultés qui sont pour partie liées
au retentissement négatif de l'image de
ce qui s'est produit à Paris malgré
l'engagement et le courage de de nos
amis la confronter à une situation et
nos collègues à une situation
extrêmement difficile l'enseignement
c'est que les problèmes d'addiction le
disait tout à l'heure c'est des
problèmes mixte c'est à dire qu'ils vont
nécessairement de pairs avec des
problèmes psychologiques en l'occurrence
psychiatrique et des problèmes sociaux
et si on sait on fait juste une salle de
manière isolée évidemment on va avoir un
problème c'est-à-dire on va avoir en
effet de sédimentation il faut
évidemment intégrer ces dispositifs
c'est le projet d'ailleurs de
l'appellation altoin addiction dans une
dynamique d'accès aux soins ouverte sur
du soin résidentiel sur des prises en
charge globales autrement évidemment on
risque entrer dans un circuit fermé sur
les cigarettes on nous demandait des
données des données récentes il y a des
données récentes il y a eu le rapport du
Haut conseil de santé publique au début
de l'année dernière il vient d'y avoir
un rapport d'une revue qu'aucun c'est
des méta-analyse médicale mais qui
tentent à ouvrir la porte du côté d'une
relative efficacité des cigarettes dans
l'aide au sevrage tabagique pour des
gens qui veulent arrêter et de fait pour
beaucoup d'usagers là aussi dans une
logique de réduction des risques qu'on
se rend compte que pour des gens qui
sont pas prêts à arrêter tout de suite
brutalement c'est une phase qui peut les
aider à
douceur si j'ose dire à se dégager du
tabac fumé souvent aussi en articulant
avec des patchs nicotiniques et de telle
façon que progressivement les personnes
pour arriver puissent arriver à un
sevrage donc à mon avis c'est une piste
vraiment à suivre en revanche côté
peuple on est comme tout le monde on est
un peu terrifié par ces nouveaux
dispositifs inventés par le marketing
avec des couleurs flashy des goûts
fraises tagada pamplemousse enfin des
choses incroyables qui sont éminemment
ciblées sur les sur les mineurs qui sont
un produit d'entrée et toute mesure qui
pourrait être prise pour restreindre
l'accès à ce type de de produits sera
bienvenu le schness c'est moins moins
présent chez nous il est très porté par
des publicités effectivement par des
sportifs et ça c'est avoir avec les
paris sportifs enfin là il y a une
espèce d'imagerie là qui est qui est
compliqué le protoxyde d'azote on en a
on en a parlé il y a eu de la loi qui
qui est passée là qui est d'une grande
aide il faut vérifier sur le terrain que
ça se passe bien la difficulté c'est que
l'on peut toujours commander sur
Internet dans la mesure des produits
ouverts des bonbonnes tout à fait
considérables et qui ensuite peuvent
être entraînés des intoxications aigus
parce que ce qui est nouveau c'est qu'il
y a des complications sanitaires très
très dommageables neurologique et
maintenant hématologie enfin c'est
vraiment quelque chose à surveiller de
de très près voilà est-ce que le crack
est diffusé on avait l'impression que
c'était un phénomène très urbain la
cocaïne on sait maintenant qu'il y en a
partout
même en milieu rural très et même mon
milieu très rural est-ce que le crack
est diffusé aussi un peu un peu
globalement sur le territoire français
la cocaïne fumée est de plus en plus
diffusée largement j'emploie ce terme
parce que c'est un peu de la le crack en
tant que tel c'est de la cocaïne basée
donc il peut être fumé parce
qu'autrement la cocaïne normale se dire
se dégrade à la chaleur donc on peut la
on peut la sniffer on peut l'injecter
mais si on la brûle elle va pas marcher
si on a on cherche la fumée donc pour
arriver à faire une une cocaïne qui
puisse être fumée il faut la baser donc
avec une base qui peut être bon enfin
peu importe et soit à ce moment-là on la
base soi-même et c'est ce qui se fait à
la campagne c'est ce qui se fait à
Bordeaux c'est à dire les gens achètent
de la cocaïne et la transforme en craque
mais eux-mêmes en fait avec un technique
de basage avec du bicarbonate ou des
choses comme ça en revanche le crack
vendu d'emblée en tant que craque donc
sous forme de de cristaux ça ça reste
pour le montrer et centré sur les
grandes villes et notamment à Paris il y
avait des populations très original
alors que la cocaïne fumée basée donc
aussi touche les populations marginales
en province dans les carrés mais pas
uniquement c'est-à-dire là on se rend
compte que ça diffuse sur des
populations plus larges y compris les
usagers traditionnels de cocaïne
beaucoup de choses ont été dites mais je
voudrais que vous remercier remercier
les les trois personnes que qui ont été
auditionnées pour le constat qu'ils ont
fait qui étaient très détaillé et
revenir sur
sur
les nouvelles drogues c'est à dire le
protoxyde d'azote et aussi la peur
électronique qui font fureur dans les
soirées et pour lesquelles bon on incite
des jeunes à consommer mais il est bien
évident que la réglementation en vigueur
n'est plus suffisante il faut vraiment
durcir
durcir la réglementation et surtout
interdire la consommation en
sanctionnant financièrement le commun le
commerce ne peuvent au mineur enfin vous
l'avez dit les uns les autres mais il
faut vraiment mettre en pratique de
nouvelles une nouvelle réglementation
alors bon moi je crois que beaucoup à la
prévention vous l'avez évoqué aussi et
la prévention qui part de nos
territoires dans les services jeunesse
citoyenneté par exemple beaucoup
beaucoup de choses peuvent être faites
et je voudrais évoquer le festival Festi
près qui a eu lieu à La Rochelle à La
Rochelle en 2022 et deux adolescentes de
mots dans mon département ont remporté
le prix du jury lors de ce dernier
festival et il s'agit de prévenir les
dangers montrer ce que ce qui peut se
passer d'ailleurs les adolescentes qui
avaient proposé ce court métrage
avait été un de leurs amis qui avait eu
un coma suite à la consommation de
protoxyde voilà bon je voulais encore
insister là-dessus parce que ça me
semble important pour
prévenir ce qui peut se passer par la
suite Jocelyne guidez ensuite Emilienne
Pomerol Olivier
merci madame la Présidente
j'avais une question sur les Jeux
olympiques mais bon on a eu la réponse
et puis Michel meunier la poser surtout
d'azote je rappelle quand même à mes
collègues qui a un rapport qui fait
dessus et voilà de le relire parce que
toutes les marques dedans et je dirais
même les dégâts que ça fait au niveau je
dirais du cerveau des jeunes donc voilà
n'hésitez pas donc ma question est
celle-ci moi tout à fait différente je
voulais savoir parce que vous avez parlé
que vous allez recevoir 24000 jeunes je
crois c'est ça 24000 jeunes
prochainement
je voudrais savoir si vous avez
interrogé notamment
les personnes qui sont atteintes des
troubles du neuro-développement
notamment sur le TDAH
puisque on connaît les addictions qui
sont liées à leur trouble notamment la
drogue mais aussi ça peut être
surprenant mais le sucre
voilà et je voulais savoir si vous les
avez interrogé
le résultat et comment vous pensez les
accompagner là-dessus je vous remercie
oui merci à la précédente merci vraiment
pour pour toutes les données que vous
nous avez fournies mais c'est vrai que
les sujets sont tellement vastes je
dirais que même une journée il suffirait
pas et que il faudrait qu'on fasse
j'allais dire des Colocs quasiment sur
chaque thème moi je voulais revenir
juste sur un thème évoqué par Laurence
sur sur le cannabis en disant qu'on est
bien d'accord sur les risques que
représente le cannabis en particulier
jusqu'à
les jeunes mais jusqu'à 25 ans
en particulier sur le plan sur le plan
cérébral bien sûr
mais quand même un constat vous dites
900000 consommateurs habituels alors ce
qui m'inquiète un peu c'est que je suis
toulousain et que l'Occitanie et le
chiffre le plus important 55% de jeunes
de moins de 1 entre 14 et 17 ans ont
essayé donc ça m'inquiète un peu pour
notre pour notre région je croyais que
le soleil pouvait faire de la prévention
mais non à l'évidence non
je voulais revenir sur le fait qu'on est
à la fois le pays le plus répressif
et en même temps le pays où le plus
consommateur
en Europe en tout cas
de cannabis et que donc force de
constater que depuis les années où il y
a de la répression sur le cannabis on
n'arrive pas à voir les résultats
et que donc
vous parlez bien de prévention et je
sais tous les efforts qui sont faits
partout en termes de prévention mais je
voulais vous demander d'ailleurs quels
sont les moyens financiers que vous avez
sur sur la prévention réellement et
comment on pourrait ne pas en arriver un
jour ou l'autre à un débat sur la
légalisation je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec ce qu'a dit votre collègue
tout à l'heure en disant que ça ne
marche nulle part parce que les exemples
au Canada en particulier ou la vente est
une vente publique organisée par l'État
avec j'allais dire un système
pour le pour le tabac production qui
permettrait d'éviter d'avoir les
mélanges et les augmentations de taux de
THC il y a actuellement par rapport à ce
qui se vend il y a 20 ans en arrière et
les mélanges dangereux qu'on constate si
c'était une production qui était
contrôlée par l'État est vendu dans des
boutiques contre les par l'État on
pourrait effectivement avoir peut-être
je ne veux pas préjugé de l'avenir mais
on peut se dire que c'est peut-être un
des moyens d'avenir d'arriver à une
diminution réelle de la consommation
en se disant que
tous les impacts effectivement sur sur
l'économie souterraine qui est
extrêmement importante au dessus sur les
violences sur le mal vivre qu'il y a
dans les quartiers prioritaires de la
ville où beaucoup de gens subissent
l'effet de ces clans et de ces de ce
trafic parce que 95% des habitants ou 98
ou 99% je ne sais ne sont pas des
trafiquants de drogue mais ils subissent
au quotidien les violences que ça
représente et on souffre beaucoup donc
voilà moi je me dis que quand même
on pourrait réfléchir et je sais bien
que c'est pas en 5 minutes maintenant
qu'on va pouvoir évoquer ce sujet mais
je crois que il est temps qu'on se pose
quand même des questions sur le cannabis
parce qu'il y a trop longtemps que on
est un peu hypocrite en disant bon vent
augmenter la répression et
l'augmentation de la répression mais ça
marche pas à l'évidence voilà
Olivier Hainaut Annick Jacques main
Catherine procacia olivierno oui merci
madame la Présidente merci pour vos
exposés je ré-abourde pas les questions
sur le protoxyde d'azote ou les
violences liées à l'alcool encore que
j'y suis assez voire très sensible mais
je voulais évoquer le le chiffre par
rapport aux jeunes qui ont des pulsions
suicidaires puisque j'ai lu 18% et je
trouve que ce chiffre est absolument
bouleversant qui a un jeune sur cinq
dans notre pays qui est des pulsions
suicidaires
qu'est-ce qui va pas
une journée où on apprend aussi que les
naissances sont en train de chuter où
c'était hier plus exactement mais enfin
il y a un mal-être dans notre société
donc avoir un peu des appréciations
qualitatives sur cette sur ce chiffre
tout à fait bouleversant puisqu'on est
passé de 11 à 18% à ce que c'est
seulement le covid est-ce que c'est
durable enfin compliqué de répondre à
ces questions quelles sont qualitatives
enfin c'est très intéressant d'avoir
votre appréciation et puis par rapport
aux jeunes
est-ce que vous voyez parce que j'ai
dans une discussion avec un ami
psychiatre il évoqué cette question le
trouble de la bipolarité
ce multiplier et si tel est le cas
qu'elles en sont les causes si vous les
avez partiellement identifié je vous
remercie
président merci Monsieur pour pour vos
exposer moi je voulais parler de la
surexposition aux écrans des enfants de
0 à 6 ans puisque j'ai été sensibilisée
notamment par les travaux de la docteur
dukanda qui met bien en évidence retard
de développement les troubles du
comportement ou alors des troubles qui
ressemblent étrangement aux troubles du
spectre de l'autisme et bon c'est que
cette surexposition aux écrans entraîne
des troubles importants du
neurodéveloppement mais aussi de la
vision puisqu'on constate que dans les
pays développés il y a de plus en plus
de problèmes de myopie et
parallèlement je suis en train de
terminer un rapport pour l'OPEX donc
l'Office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologies sur
la pollution lumineuse et dans toutes
les auditions que j'ai fait on m'a aussi
sensibilisé au risque de la lumière
bleue sur les yeux des enfants enfants
notamment puisqu'ils ont un cristallin
qui est très transparent alors je
voulais savoir
ce qui était fait et ce que déjà vous
docteur en tant que médecin pique
psychiatre vous avez pu travailler sur
les conséquences de cette exposition des
plus jeunes aux écrans numériques et
selon vous comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
prévenir ces pratiques et j'aurais voulu
savoir aussi
justement ce qui était prévu dans le
cadre du futur plan national de
mobilisation quand les addictions de
2023 à 2027 est-ce que ce sujet de santé
concernant les enfants de 0,6 ans a été
bien identifié et surtout quels sont les
solutions parce que je reste un petit
peu sur ma faim on a évoqué beaucoup
d'addiction que ça soit le tabac
l'alcool les jeux d'argent le protoxyde
d'azote alors bon j'ai bien entendu
qu'il fallait renforcer les contrôles
qu'il fallait être plus vigilant que les
mères devaient aussi exerc c'est le rôle
mais voilà je reste un petit peu sur ma
sein ma faim parce que je voudrais
savoir concrètement ce qui est prévu
justement dans le dans le plan à venir
et voilà qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire en
pratiquant pratique j'allais dire
sur le terrain merci pour terminer
Catherine progacia j'en avais des
questions mais c'était l'ami des cas tu
peux poser quand même et puis ce sera
transmis
la présidence avait justement évoqué
pour débuter la priorité par rapport au
tabac or
dans le plan national de santé moi je
m'étonne de l'absence de recherche
sérieuse on a évoqué et je remercie mes
collègues qui ont appelé
les pubs et les l'amendements qui
avaient été voté au Sénat qui a pas été
retenu pour le gouvernement mais vous
dites vous-même qu'il n'y a pas d'études
donc moi je est-ce que vous pouvez faire
quelque chose parce que par rapport aux
études on a aucune étude sérieuse vous
avez simplement évoqué
les cigarettes électroniques mais on n'a
pas d'études sérieuses sur les les peufs
alors à qui est un mode de
d'introduction au tabac contrairement
aux cigarettes électroniques qui sont
pour s'échapper du testament pourquoi ne
lance-t-on pas une une étude on n'a pas
d'évaluation sur le tabac à chauffer
on nous dit que le tabac chauffé est
moins addictif et en tout cas qu'il est
destiné aux personnes qui
vous ne veulent pas s'arrêter de fumer
mais qu'il serait moins dangereux on n'a
pas d'études là-dessus et sur les snuffs
moi j'ai eu une audition et j'ai été
étonné d'entendre
des personnes qui ne fabriquent pas
enfin qui ne sont pas dans S9 des
associations lutte contre le tabac nous
dire que c'était plutôt favorable donc
est-ce que
vous pouvez vous pouvez m'expliquer
pourquoi on lance pas d'études sérieuses
en France sur ce sujet et celle à
l'étranger ne concerne pas les nouveaux
modes puisque ils sont tout à faits
jantes
je suis désolé elles étaient dédiées à
Madame citoyenne mais elle a dû nous
quitter moi j'avais trois questions
sachant que le plan national de lutte
contre les addictions
il est arrivé à échéance donc j'ai cru
entendre qu'il y avait une stratégie qui
allait être mise en place pour les cinq
années à venir donc j'aurais souhaité
avant de sa part un éclairage
un bilan aussi des chefs de projet qui
mi des cas qui avait été
mise en place en région je ne sais pas
où on en est et enfin
ou à une été l'ami dès le cas par
rapport à un certain nombre d'actions
qui font partie de ces missions au-delà
de nos frontières notamment par rapport
à tous ces produits qui traversent nos
frontières de plus en plus et qui font
des dégâts voilà c'était simplement mais
mes trois questions merci
bon écoutez je vous laisse répondre si
on n'a pas les je n'avais pas la réponse
aux questions destinées toutes les
questions on interrogera la ville des
cas pour qu'elle ne réponde par écrit
bien que les gens
de thématique qui ont été abordées
concernant le protoxyde d'azote qu'un
sujet sur lequel l'autre commission et
commission des Lois du Sénat nous avait
interrogé au moment donc la promotion de
loi de 2019
juste pour vous indiquer que cette
automne l'Agence européenne des drogues
du MCD a publié un rapport sur
l'étendue du phénomène au niveau
européen je pense que c'est un c'est
aussi une ressource intéressante en
termes de mesure de mise en place pour
contrôler la diffusion de ce produit
dans un centre de pays de l'Union
européenne voilà il y a toute une
analyse comparative des législations
prises par les différents pays et on
voit que dans les pays comme les
Pays-Bas ou le Danemark qui sont comme
comme chez nous relativement touché par
ce phénomène chez les jeunes les
dispositifs législatifs qui ont été pris
ou réglementaires ont aussi évolué dans
le temps puisque comme ça a été évoqué
les acteurs de l'offre Chan leur méthode
la méthode de diffusion c'est une
ressource tout à fait intéressante avec
des cas d'analyse thématiques par pour 6
pays dont la France c'est un point de
questions sur le grec et sur la
diffusion de la cocaïne on va nous
publier au mois de mars 2023 une
synthèse des dernières données est
disponible concernant
l'actualité de des usages de cocaïne
dans notre pays comme le rappelait
Jean-Michel de Lille les dernières
données qu'on aime sur les
patients qui sont pris en charge dans
les Sapa on voit on a vu effectivement
ces cinq dernières années une très forte
augmentation du nombre de demandes de
traitement pour la cocaïne fumée donc
c'est à dire les usagers de cocaïne basé
qui sont donc pour les ceux qui se
s'approvisionnent auprès d'un marché
structuré qu'on appelle le crack mais
qui se diffuse comme ça a été évoqué par
Jean-Michel de Lille par
par le basage soit par l'US lui-même
soit par des proches mais qui ne fait
pas lieu qui ne donne pas lieu d'un
marché structuré on a assez peu enfin on
a très peu de d'exemples de marché
structurés du crack de crack de produits
de crack en dehors de Paris on a il y a
quelques quelques points de vigilance
sur en région on vient de réaliser à la
demande de l'agence régionale de santé
des Pays de la Loire une enquête sur les
sur les effectivement les
usages auprès des publics les plus
précarisés dans les en dehors de de la
métropole nantaise donc
en Mayenne en dans la Sarthe et dans le
Maine-et-Loire donc voilà on rendra
public ces résultats avec l'agence
régionale de santé fin février donc
c'est voilà ces éléments qui seront je
pense au regard de donc c'est vrai qu'il
y a pas eu d'interroger plus d'une
soixantaine de professionnels et
d'usagers sur sur cette région et je
pense les résultats seront aussi
intéressants pour vous et enfin sur le
sur toute la question concernant la
législation du cannabis
on s'est attaché à cette question de
compréhension des modèles qui étaient
mis en oeuvre à l'étranger avec une
première étude qui avait été réalisée en
2016-2017 et depuis 2019 avec le
financement du fond addiction on mène un
projet qui s'appelle astrakan et qui
permet de mesurer les modèles de
légalisation de régulation du cannabis
qui ont été mis en oeuvre au Canada et
aux États-Unis dans dans 6 juridictions
dans 6 états trois au Canada et 3 aux
États-Unis il y a des éléments déjà des
éléments d'analyse qui sont disponibles
sur notre site mais on aura
effectivement au printemps enfin plutôt
à la fin du premier semestre 2023 la
synthèse de ces résultats c'est je pense
intéressant pour votre commission
puisque s'il y a un autre un autre temps
de réflexion
on a maintenant pour certains États
américains près de 10 ans de de recul
sur les effets effectivement à la fois
sur les sur une plus grande diffusion
des consommateurs enfin du produit chez
les adultes
mais par ailleurs un vrai contrôle et
une baisse des UHC chez les chez les
mineurs et puis je vais pas le détailler
ici mais un certain nombre de points qui
est de vigilance concernant les
conséquences sanitaires de ces usages en
population adulte voilà c'est ce que je
voulais réévoquer sur différents sujets
qui nous concernent directement juste
puisque je sais que la question des
peufs du SNES a été évoqué plusieurs
reprises ça va être lorsqu'on fait des
enquêtes en population adolescentes ou
des enquêtes en général on a d'abord
pour que nos les résultats que l'on
obtient nous permettent de les analyser
c'est qu'on on doit pouvoir les comparer
dans le temps donc quand on a des
phénomènes marketing qui apparaissent de
manière très très rapide généralement on
est en décalage toujours dans les dans
les enquêtes en 2017 dans l'enquête
escapade on avait manqué les questions
sur le protoxyde d'azote qui est apparu
donc
il faut toujours être vigilant sur le
fait que qu'un phénomène s'il est
visible médiatiquement parlant dans la
rue n'est pas forcé sans doute pas
forcément une diffusion massive dans
l'ensemble de manière générale sur toute
une génération de public donc ça c'est
un point de vigilance on a pu poser on
l'avait présenté l'année dernière on
sait qu'on a 5,5 % des un peu moins de
6% donc des jeunes de 3e qui ont déjà
expérimenté le protoxyde d'azote dans
une enquête qu'on mène en milieu
scolaire on va on a René cette enquête
en milieu scolaire en 2000 au premier
semestre 2022 et on aura à la rentrée
donc de septembre 2022 des nouvelles de
nez sur la diffusion effectivement du
protoxyde d'azote qui pourrait être
comparé aux données de 2021 donc ça
c'est un premier point on est on sait
qu'on est quand même faire un produit
qui est relativement fortement diffusé
auprès des jeunes mais quand je dis
relativement fortement on est dans un
tour de 10% on n'est pas on n'est pas la
moitié on n'est pas sur des niveaux de
diffusion qu'on a pu connaître au début
des années 2000 comme je le disais tout
à l'heure sur le tabac ou qu'on le
connaît encore aujourd'hui comme la
rappeler valait Saint-Aignan sur
l'alcool ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
être vigilant faut pas dire qu'il ne
faut pas contrôler mais il faut
effectivement
être attentif lorsqu'il y a des nouveaux
produits voir si c'est effectivement un
phénomène qui qui apparaît et qui va
disparaître on avait eu le cas pour les
cigarettes électroniques
marketing type Jules il y a il y a 55 il
faut savoir que les jeunes sont aussi
très réactifs c'est une entreprise qui a
été rachetée par l'industrie du tabac et
qui a en fait qui a quasiment disparu en
fait dans dans les pratiques de
consommation donc la vigilance et ça a
été rappelé à plusieurs reprises sur le
et nous on pose cette question on essaie
de la comprendre dans les enquêtes en
population générale c'est sur ces
cigarettes type puff en fait la question
c'est que les jeunes qui expérimentent
cette cigarette ne savent pas exactement
ce qu'il fume ce qui ce qui est le Zinal
pour être plus précis s'il y a de la
nicotine s'il y a pas de nicotine et
l'enjeu principal c'est effectivement
enfin de prévenir l'addiction à nicotine
qui peut après entraîner des
consommations de cigarettes qui sont
plus facilement accessibles
bien docteur Delile vous souhaitez
rajouter quelque chose
une question très précise sur l'enquête
escapade excusez-moi de ne pas y avoir
répondu donc sinon enquête qui est faite
auprès de 24000 jeunes qui sont tirés
aléatoirement donc sur enfin non ils
sont pas qui sont qui passent sur une
semaine donnée la journée d'appel donc
la journée défense hydrienne t donc ils
sont convoqués par le ministère des
armées donc c'est c'est aléatoire donc
il y a sans doute des jeunes parmi ces
ces 24000 qui avait un trouble de
l'attention mais nous on ne le sait pas
et les questions qui sont posées en
termes de santé permettront pas de
déterminer mais je suis certain que
Jean-Michel devenu avec sa pratique de
terrain pourra vous donner des éléments
par rapport à ça
oui alors très très rapidement un
premier point sur la prévention suite à
ce qui était dit
à l'issue de Festi prevent à La Rochelle
je crois quand des parmi les acteurs
majeurs en matière de prévention il y a
les personnes elles-mêmes et notamment
les jeunes et on sait que les messages
portés par des jeunes même sont souvent
plus accessibles et plus compréhensible
et plus acceptable surtout par par
d'autres jeunes alors là ce qui nous
sert en gros de mon point de vue
notamment par rapport à des produits
comme le cannabis c'est paradoxalement
l'explosion des usages à la fin des
années 90 ce qui fait que beaucoup de
jeunes sont devenus des usagers de
cannabis mais beaucoup ont vu aussi les
dégâts que ça faisait sur d'autres
jeunes si bien qu'ils ont pu juger par
eux-mêmes que le cannabis n'était pas
aussi inoffensif que ce qui était dit
auparavant ou en fait il y avait deux
visions cloisonnées les jeunes pensaient
que c'était il y avait rien à craindre
c'était une panacée et les adultes en
gros pensaient que c'était pas bon
dangereux donc c'était assimilé discours
moralistes alors que là en fait la
réalité éclate c'est j'espère ce qui va
apparaître bientôt et le protoxyde
d'azote c'est à dire que les jeunes
eux-mêmes se rendent compte que
finalement c'est pas anodin et peuvent
développer des messages de prévention
qui sont très audibles quitte à charge à
nous ensuite de les relayer y compris
sur les réseaux sociaux et sur les les
supports médias utilisent les les jeunes
même donc ça à mon avis c'est une grosse
piste vous ne demandiez si nos moyens
étaient suffisants non les moyens de
prévention pour l'aspect consultation
jeune consommateurs c'est-à-dire
repérage précoce prévention primo
secondaire ça c'est intégré à notre
dotation globale donc globalement ça ça
fonctionne en revanche là où il y a des
gros problèmes c'est toutes les actions
de prévention autre sont financés à
l'année et pratiquement donc avec
l'insécurité qu'on connaît tous dans ce
type de problématique alors sur le TDAH
donc le trouble déficit de la tension
avec hyperactivité clairement parmi les
troubles neuro-développementaux c'est
celui qui est le plus prédictif de
risque de passage à l'addiction au
moment de de l'adolescence il y a un
lien structurel très très important qui
nécessite là aussi décloisonner les
filières santé mentale pédopsie et
addict de telle façon que on sait bien
le repérage précoce du TDAH et son
accompagnement son traitement précoce
c'est vrai aussi pour le trouble
bipolaire chez les enfants peut
permettre de réduire à ce moment-là le
risque d'évoluer vers une addiction donc
ça c'est bien l'autre élément c'est pour
ça qu'il faut des cloisonner c'est que
parfois se repérage est pas bien fait
j'avais participé un groupe de travail à
Las sur le repérage en médecine de
première ligne enfin il y a beaucoup de
travail parce que là vraiment bon ça
chemine en revanche il faut qu'il y ait
une voiture balai si j'ose dire la
voiture balai ça peut être et
consultation je ne consommateur parce
que quand on voit des jeunes qui perdent
le contrôle au moment de l'adolescence
par rapport à des produits le premier
truc il faut vérifier c'est s'ils ont
pas un TDAH donc il faut que des équipes
comme les nôtres
apprennent en fait à faire du repérage
et de l'accompagnement au traitement
avec les difficultés qu'il y a avec la
pédopsie mais c'est une grosse piste et
y compris donc pour la bipolarité alors
le cannabis on y avait pas répondu la
première fois la Fédération addiction de
longue date et favorable à du
dépénalisation d'usage parce qu'on n'a
pas le sentiment que la pénalisation
amène de gros effets ce qui veut pas
dire qu'il interdit il faut interdire il
faut interdire aux mineurs faut
interdire au travail il faut interdire
au volant etc mais de telle façon que
l'interdiction là aussi soit appuyé sur
un fondement rationnel aisément
transmissible et aisément alors la
légalisation
l'expérience qui nous intéresse mais ça
a été évoqué effectivement c'est que aux
États-Unis est à fédéral davantage qu'on
a des points de comparaison entre
différentes formes de légalisation et il
apparaît que peut-être la piste la plus
intéressante celle qui est utilisée dans
certains états de l'Est américain qu'on
voit aussi au Canada notamment au Québec
donc avec une égalisation contrôlée
c'est celle qui peut peut-être permettre
d'avoir un impact en termes économique
sociétal etc sans avoir des dommages
induits en santé publique qui soit trop
trop important alors d'ici là nous ce
qu'on a proposé nous à l'agence du du
médicament enfin dans le cas de
expérimentation cannabis thérapeutique
donc vous savez qu'elle vient d'être
prolongée c'est d'étendre l'indication
du cannabis thérapeutique aux gens
dépendant du cannabis adulte
c'est-à-dire au moins pour ceux qui
entrent 35 40 45 ans
qui sont dépendants du cannabis plutôt
que de les renvoyer Audi à ce monde-là
pourquoi ne pas effectivement les faire
entrer dans un circuit médical et
élargir à ce moment-là le circuit de
distribution du cannabis thérapeutique
d'être mis en place dans notre pays
vis-à-vis d'autres indications notamment
en neurologie donc ça me semblerait être
une voie intermédiaire qui permettrait
d'avancer l'alcool les aidants c'était
évoqué précédemment et vous avez évoqué
des problèmes des violences c'est un
élément un élément clé alors suite au
Grenay sur les violences conjugales on
avait fait valoir la présence la forte
présence de substances psychoactives
notamment l'alcool mais pas uniquement
le cannabis la cocaïne dans les
violences faites aux femmes et notamment
et violences conjugales si bien que au
moment où ont été mis en place les
centres de prise en charge des auteurs
de violences conjugales mais aussi des
centres d'accompagnement des victimes de
violences conjugales habituellement on
essaie de faire en sorte que les que ça
part environnant soit aussi à ses
initiatives là de telle façon qu'ils
puissent proposer un accompagnement aux
auteurs pour limiter les risques de
récidive et surtout évidemment en
accompagnement aux victimes qui sont
souvent aussi sous l'emprise de
substance il faut il faut bien le
reconnaître et où ça peut les aider à
être aidé à faire un travail de groupe
sur ce sur ce plan-là avec un intérêt
particulier pour tout ce qui est
traitement précoce du stress post
traumatique mais si on parle comme
morbidité psychiatrique et à les
troubles neurodéveloppementaux mais
notamment chez les femmes le risque de
basculer vers l'addiction clairement
c'est les antécédents de violence ces
antécédents de stress post traumatiques
et là oui oui tout à fait et donc avec
une nécessité impérative là aussi de les
prendre dans les de les prendre en
compte alors sur la question sur les les
pensées suicidaires je pense que ça
c'est vraiment accentué au moment du
confinement ce qu'on peut rattacher
clairement à l'isolement c'est à dire on
sait que
l'adolescence et le moment où on a le
plus besoin du regard des autres des
autres pairs des copains etc pour
arriver à se tenir à avancer et là il y
a eu une rupture brutale de de avec un
isolement total ça a été un point de
fragilisation il y a beaucoup d'enquêtes
qui ont montré qu'après les in études
pour la survie de leurs parents de leurs
proches la deuxième préoccupation
c'était pas voir copain c'était ça le
voisin 8 les perspectives sociétales
d'avenir de boulot de crises planétaire
déco anxiété enfin il y a toutes sortes
de mécanismes de fond mais je pense
qu'il y a eu un effet déclencheur du du
de l'isolement il faudra voir si à terme
justement c'est ça revient à la norme
qui était déjà préoccupante ou si on
reste à ces niveaux très très élevés qui
seraient vraiment très très préoccupant
alors sur la surexposition aux écrans et
les troubles neuro-développementaux
clairement le on disait tout à l'heure
que par exemple le TDAH est un facteur
de risque pour l'addiction mais les
écrans sont le facteur de risque pour le
TDAH donc on va bien comment tout ça est
en interaction est en interaction
permanente et il faut agir alors comment
le plan je sais pas ce qui te dira la
stratégie mais en tout cas de 0 à 6 ans
on est encore globalement sous le
contrôle de ses parents donc là il y a
vraiment tout un
bon peuvent snuff on a répondu j'espère
qu'il aurait été tellement faire des
études mais je je n'en doute pas et puis
les questions sur la mamie des cannes
concerne pas
une question avant qu'on termine merci
beaucoup pour pour cette audition est-ce
que vous avez un regard sur les rêves
des rêves partir parce que alors ça doit
être dans le surement dans le dans le
guide du maire parce que toutes les
communes sont confrontées moi j'ai
l'impression que c'était un peu en
baisse un peu moins parlé dans la presse
locale néanmoins en rentrant l'autre
jour le 2 janvier on a croisé dans une
commune en effet des tas de groupes de
jeunes qui marchaient le long de la
route est quand même vraiment le look le
truc de d'une fin de rave party à 15h ou
16 heures de l'après-midi vous regardez
vous suivez qui suis ça un peu les
histoires de rêve partout ce sont
vraiment des lieux de consommation
on appelle l'espace festif électronique
non non
les rêves en font partie les free
parties des mais également en fait
d'espace festif commerciaux qui qui
emploie les mêmes codes autour des
musiques électroniques ça fait partie
d'un des espaces d'observation de FDT
depuis plus de 20 ans dans le cadre de
notre dispositif tendance récente et
nouvelle drogue on publie la semaine
prochaine la synthèse des résultats donc
des des 8 coordinations locales sur le
territoire hexagonal donc sur l'année
2021 et le début de l'année 2022 donc la
synthèse sera disponible la semaine
prochaine avec un focus effectivement
sur la reprise
il y a eu pendant
toute la période du confinement en fait
une moindre diffusion de ces du fait à
la fois des restrictions de circulation
des couvre-feu mais voilà il y a quand
même enfin le mouvement existe toujours
il y a toujours une activité qui qui est
à la fois importante à la fois sur
l'espace alternatif et sur l'espace
commercial et ça reste pour nous un lieu
d'observation parce que c'est aussi un
lieu de diffusion et de consommation de
produits qui est important un lieu où un
certain nombre d'installation de
réduction des risques interviennent
également et donc voilà il y a un
certain nombre de vigilance sur la
diffusion de nouveaux produits on a
parlé tout à l'heure très rapidement de
des catinos de synthèse et de la 3 MMC
mais voilà ça on voit que ça peut se
diffuser dans ce type d'espace et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on continue les
observer de manière régulière
merci beaucoup merci pour cette matinée
d'échange beaucoup de questions et
bon courage pour la suite